guys welcome to the just pearly things
youtube channel and welcome to the
pregame
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos and
guys this is our first episode in our
new studio thank you all so much for
making this happen yay new studio
[Music]
[Applause]
okay guys um so i have a couple
announcements one of which being that we
have two clips channels now we have two
different editors on them so if you guys
want a little bit different like types
of clips different types of content we
have a second clips channels it's called
pearl daily that is in the description
on top of that we have three membership
tiers we have the five dollar tier the
second half of the show is going to be
members only the 10 tier if you guys
want to see this is a pretty cool
penthouse right guys yes if you guys
want to see behind the scenes footage
first look of the penthouse it's under
the dollar tier we're going to do a vlog
um the view is good right right hell
yeah
you guys want to see it sign up for the
10 tier on top of that if you want to
get onto tier 3 you can connect with us
on social media and on tier 4 you get a
one-on-one call with me once a month i
can even do like um youtube
consultations so you know you could be
the first one no one signed up for that
one yet um also my instagram is just dot
pearly things i'm getting close to 50k
on instagram so go follow my instagram
also y'all they took away my first tick
tock account
they took away my second tick tock
account they took away my third tick
tock account but i am on tick tock
number four so go follow my fourth tick
tock it's just pearly things dot four
because some someone took the username
just pearly things four because they
knew i was going to take it so that was
bogus whoever did that um on top of that
we have a member of the week dragon
stallion one zero zero one we have a
members only live once a month so i
believe we're going to do that maybe in
like two wednesdays
and if you guys want to come on the show
dm eddie um he's our recruiter the link
to his instagram is in the description
he's here today you wanna you can put
him on camera
yeah so dm dm eddie
um so today we have a lovely panel so
why don't we go around
everyone say your name your age your
relationship status and where you're
from and if you want you can do a fun
fact
so yeah you can start
hi my name is linda i'm 20 years old
i'm single and a fun fact about me is i
don't want to get fired hence my face
covering
i'm ria i'm 28 years old i'm in a
relationship and a fun fact about me is
that i have free cats
hi i'm diontee and i'm 28 years old
i'm single and the fun fact about me is
i love to write
hi my name's jack i'm 26 years old i am
married
since this relationship podcast so fun
fact about me is that one time i was
living with my ex and girlfriend at the
same time
wait wait wait actually
how did that go
horribly but i would come back because
it was my own apartment i'd come back
and one of them would like mess the
other's room or they'd tell me like i
want to make a coffee can you go in
there and make a coffee i was like this
is horrible wait wait so
i know we're in the intro how did that
like happen it was um so i lived on my
own and then
my ex texted me like a year later saying
i just broke up with my boyfriend the
one she cheated on me with and was like
i need a place to live can i live you
said yes
after she cheated well because the thing
was i wanted to get out of my current
relationship as well but
so you only have two birds one stone yes
i have tried and then basically so then
i was living with her and then my
girlfriend calls me she was at uni at
the time she calls me she goes ice my
summer break can i come over and i was
like
um i've got something to tell you i've
been live with my ex for the last like
three months can you um
can you come over and stuff like that
but yes and i live with both of them but
yeah i won't take up time
wow
my name is dear linda i'm 28 i'm taken
and i'm here with my two best friends
i'm drew i'm 63 and uh single
and fun fact um
i know how computer chips work
oh
what kind of computer chip
uh microcontrollers
don't know what that means
there's probably about a hundred of them
in this room
oh okay they're all over the place
okay um so today's topic is we are
talking about the bare minimum
um who here has heard the term i
accepted the bare minimum
yeah let's go around yeah yes
um and typically this is um something i
hear from women and it's like i accepted
the bare minimum
so my first question is what is the bare
minimum
start with you
oh i'm not sure um
just being around i guess
okay go ahead
the bare minimum
um
yeah spending time that's the birmingham
okay
um
how would i explain this
i don't know
yeah like you said just being around but
not making any effort at all
okay yeah
can i have an example of that just like
this um
so you're around and you're saying oh i
love you or oh yeah we're going to do
this in the future and there's no
actions behind anything you say okay so
it's like it's like he's not really
spending time yeah exactly okay okay
oh well i mean i've never actually heard
the term but if i was taking a guess
maybe it would be like a bare minimum
standard or like like to cope with with
a partner
the minimums need to be maximized um
well then i want to be a minimum would
be a maximum
it's like the small things matter so
it's like give me all the small little
things like ways of affection okay
uh i i haven't heard the term either but
they're again i'm a boomer so hardly
surprising um speaking to the mic
i haven't heard the term before myself
so um
hard to say really uh
i expect more i mean what can i say um
i wouldn't accept the bare minimum
that's all i can say really
what do you feel like should be the bare
minimum that's required from a man
in dating yeah and dating and
someone like that wants to be your
boyfriend um i think persistence okay
yeah persistence take me out
does he need to pay
yeah
yeah that's the bare minimum
what percent of the time are you are you
talking about like once you're dating
should he pay 100 of the time the first
time the first day you should 100
definitely pay and then after that i
will like you know offer to pay but you
don't you don't really want that you
still meant to say no it's fine i got
this but you know i will i hold my own
so i will you know offer to pay okay but
like you're kind of would you be annoyed
if if he said okay yeah go ahead
i'll get up and walk away at night
i'll just pay and then i'll just be like
all right now i see you i see
and will you not see him after that or
would you still see him i'll probably
give him one more chance if he does it
justice league or is it cooked yeah
um for me
it would just be like respect loyalty
you know
yeah stuff like that okay do you want me
to answer for a guy awful girl oh shoot
no we're going to do guys next
um i want you to be obsessed with me to
be honest
yes like i want you to text me call me
all the time but then don't be too much
not overbearing so i have a question um
is there someone you think of like the
guy you loved the most like one guy that
comes to mind yeah
was he obsessed with you yeah okay
usually i find that it's not the same
like usually it's like the guy that the
girl likes the most like isn't obsessed
with them at all really yeah
nah i i feel like
like texting you daily
nice dates is that like your type of
yeah but like i i want i want the
minimum conversation maybe or maybe
minimal standard like oh good morning
have a good night kind of thing okay it
doesn't have to be a full-on
conversation all the time but show me
that you're interested what about dates
should he pay 100 of the time um
i mean if they're trying to court me
like they quoted all the ladies back in
the day you should be paying no like
all of this is not free
but then obviously as things like evolve
then i don't mind splitting or
going halfway you know so i i have a
question um are you a virgin
no no no no okay i just i would assume
not just you know but
i don't know so do you do you feel like
it's it's fair that we require
traditional like the man paying when
we're not traditional women because
we're not virgins anymore
um
that's a tough question
but you have to try before you buy no
[Music]
are you going are you gonna go all the
way in without knowing where you're
getting yourself they used to they used
to and then they're all unhappy with
like 10 kids and just staying at home
taking care of the children not really
the divorce rate's higher now yeah now
because women want more
we demand
yeah are we worth more hell yeah
really yeah especially now because women
are so independent you know that's why i
think our value is way higher i think
our value is lower than ever before in
all of human history yeah we're like the
lowest value women possible on the
planet because men men value purity and
youth so the average age of first
marriage in the uk is 31 that's not
young and by 31 how many bodies you got
so so it's that offering to the things
that men value
so it's like how can we say it's like
you're requiring a a higher price for a
used product
not used experienced
because are you really going to get into
a relationship or a situation with
someone who doesn't have the experience
or the tools
to maybe
you know um make you a better person or
help you learn new things like we're
here to help each other so see i think
you've got to bring something to the
table yeah but i think that's a very
feminine mindset because like in your
head
as women i think we like project our
mindset onto men sometimes
and so
and so like from a woman's point of view
you do want a guy that's experienced and
that you can learn from but like from a
man's point of view they prefer men
there are women that are more pure
yeah but they're not fair then you want
to be showered and babied and taken care
of like i'm your mother so
maybe maybe the men you pick you know
that's not that's not all men though i
feel like all men have that sense of
like being they want to be taken care of
to a certain extent i think that yeah
they want someone that's like kind and
nurturing i would agree with you but
they also want a lot of similar
qualities like their mother
i mean i think they want someone that
would raise the kids so like they want
someone with motherly qualities because
they if they want a wife they need
someone to raise the kids
but like a guy that's worth a damn he
can take care of himself
unless you're dating like bombs
do you actually believe that guys like
go for people who are like their mothers
yeah to a certain extent because i feel
like similar qualities like so so i'm
probably a rare case right i grew up
with just a single dad so no mama at all
so it's like i find that like statement
like
a bit weird for me personally obviously
because i don't know what like but did
you have any like female role models in
your life nope but i had my brother my
dad that's it so yeah that's it and my
dad did the cooking ironing worked every
day did everything
wow
yeah i guess i mean we're not all the
same you know yeah yeah i mean usually
we're speaking in general terms though
right well and if you if you if we're
gonna compare apples and oranges oranges
kids that come from single father out
homes tend to have better outcomes than
people that come from single mother home
so you could argue that like
women or men take care of themselves
better than women because like women we
have more debt we even though we make
less money
yeah yeah i think you're right because
when my when my parents divorced it was
like the reason why i went with my dad
was because he was financially stable
yeah but my mother wasn't so we that is
better for the kid in in at the end of
the day unless like you know your mom's
gonna marry a rich dude or something
like that
i don't know i feel like i don't know
with raising kids finance yes is helpful
but then your morals
are the most important because one
person can have a lot of money but if
they have no morals
and no decorum no no sense of like
acting like a person then your child is
all ready can they learn that from their
dad though why does it have to just no i
never said that it has nothing
but i'm just saying even if they have
the finances doesn't mean that that
child is going to end up good or in a
good place
no no you're correct but even even so
it's like this the kid that's in a
single mother home is more at a
statistical disadvantage than a single
father home like he's more likely to
drop out of school more likely to go to
prison more like all the statistical dis
disadvantages that you have like tend to
be from single mother homes as opposed
to this is that more males or females or
both what do you mean like the child is
a male or female or
well by and large like men tend to be
more aggressive i mean um
as
like a whole like they're more
disagreeable so they tend to go to jail
more so i would guess it's probably more
men okay
um so what about you guys do you think
what is the bare minimum that you feel
like is required from a female i'll let
uh drew on go ahead
thanks
um
somebody who's honest and
forthright
um
i think communication is
the most important thing in a
relationship
absolute
trust
you know and trust is based on
communication understanding with it
understanding each other
um
so that's what that's
what i've always looked for first and
foremost
to be honest well i mean you know
obviously there are the physical
elements to start off with but
but then
you know that only lasts so long and
after that it really is about trust and
communication or communication and
building trust what about like cooking
cleaning do you feel like that's a bare
minimum from someone you would take
seriously
like if you're if you're paying for 100
of the dates let's just say in the early
stages
what would you require from the woman
that's a good interesting point i mean i
i'm personally i'm
independent enough to be able to cook
and uh
and all of that kind of thing but um
i think that if a woman
isn't able to do that it's kind of a bit
of a negative thing really if she's not
able to do that kind of thing yeah and
you know in a lot of instances
they make a virtue of not being able to
cook not being able to clean not wanting
to clean it
yeah
it's like somebody that isn't a virtue
not for me as far as i'm concerned i
don't expect you to do it
but if you don't do it then
sorry what do you do
so
um if so if you're dating someone early
stages what do you expect from her
like just like how we talk to the women
and they say i expect him to pay early
on like what do you expect i think um
i think things have changed
very recently as far as as far as uh
expecting
you know
to be taken to novikov and uh
and
you know that kind of thing that's
that's very very new you know i mean uh
you know i grew up during the 60s and
70s and sure as hell didn't do that kind
of stuff it was all 50 50. it was all
going dutch that's what they called it
and that's only changed very recently
um
so
no i you know if
if a young lady was to um
to
uh
expect me to pay
then
uh that wouldn't come as a big surprise
to me but it wouldn't be a positive
it wouldn't be a positive sign so so for
for me with the paying side of things
usually i will pay anyway like usually
but what i actually want like this is
how i kind of judge it is for the woman
to at least offer or at least offer to
pay half right she doesn't actually have
to pay half but it's just kind of like a
respect thing like she would just be
like no no i'll pay half and and she
doesn't have to you can just then say no
no don't worry i'll deal with it and and
that's fine but it's just like i'd like
her to do that yeah in in terms of what
i look for
yeah it's 100 physical first um but
after that i actually look at for
education but not in terms of like
academic what i mean is just like
educated and manners educated in in life
educated and like i really couldn't deal
with someone who's just like uneducated
about just how the world works or how
things things actually are so that's a
big like a huge turnout for me yeah
that's that is a very good point what
about what about like what do you
require that she do if you're taking her
out on dates and courting her
um i mean for me honestly it's just like
having a good time or be up for for
doing things right if i want to do
things i want her to also want to do do
those do those things with me um i don't
actually require personally like someone
to cook or clean like i am married and
my wife does does do those things she
didn't before so like she had never
cooked before she didn't clean around
the house she was just an english
teacher
and the fact was when when we lived live
together she just started doing those
things naturally so it's kind of the
same thing like she she just decided
okay i'm gonna help you out i'm gonna
gonna do these things for you
so why do you think women complain more
about settling when we require more from
men
we can just exist
where men have to actually bring
something to the table and do things
because they're never satisfied go ahead
go ahead speaking to the mac story
because they're never satisfied
i mean it's in the nature of women not
to be satisfied
and so
uh
so any uh anyone that they choose to
eventually end up with they will
consider that to be settling
i think maybe they're just always trying
to aim higher like
it's like um yeah like you said
uncertainty yeah but but like i is is
the unrealistic thing right because i do
have a different experience my wife is
from china which which have more
traditional values like try get married
early things like that yeah um
and and they just don't like do the
instagram stuff don't do tinder really
like some do like i can't speak for the
whole whole of that but yeah it's just
the tinder and like instagram world has
changed the whole like
view of everything i feel like what do
you guys think who settles more men are
women
definitely women okay why
i think women
well women certain women get to this
certain point where they just
can't be asked to do the whole day in
thing and getting to know someone so
they just tend to settle or sometimes
they settle for the baby daddy that's
giving them issues because they have a
child together
um i feel like because women you know
growing up we take
such maybe that's why settles more
better women i think women i think
women settle more
because one they might feel like
okay i'm getting older i'm lonely
so
i'll just settle for any guy and as well
you know we've got a body clock and you
know we want to have kids and things
like that so maybe a thing where
okay i'll just settle with this guy so i
can have kids and
just situations like that where you just
feel like oh there's a lot of times you
feel like there's no good men out there
so let me just go for the options
[Laughter]
i think men settle more because i don't
think
women in my generation at least are
taught what a woman is supposed to
provide to a man
and so
they just kind of expect that because
this is what they want in a man that
this is what they're supposed to be at
least that's what i was told is like be
who you want to date but it's not really
true
what do you guys think who settles more
men are women guys
it's a really tricky one but it's a
really tricky one this because
um
it's not a matter of settling
it's not a matter of uh
like you say well i'll just go with this
guy you know you you only get to settle
if you have a lot of choice
yeah
and that's that's the reason why i would
say that women probably settle more than
men do because men don't have as much
choice by some considerable margin
so um unless of course they are the you
know the alpha
you know most men
um
no they don't they don't settle they
have one or two opportunities they
they you know they find somebody that
suits them
i think
you know they don't i don't think their
expectations are as high so
so
you know you can call that settling if
you like but i think that because women
have a good deal more
i think it depends what you mean by
settling right so like i think men
settle for what they can get like most
most men because because uh like if i
speak to my friends
they only have they don't get girls
coming to them all the time right so
when they do get a girl it's like well
this is all i've got so i'm gonna try
settle so that's that's what i think and
i think because girls have more choice
it's it's harder for them to
sorry settle in in today's today's age
if you mean like settle like as in okay
this is what i'm gonna settle for like
i'm gonna settle for this type of woman
or this one like type of thing because
some men only get like
that choice yeah what's the difference
between so what specifically you guys
what is the difference between settling
and that's just your level
so the girl because i you said something
like oh she's just gonna go with her
baby daddy because you know even though
he gives her problems but isn't that
just her level because she can't get
anything better but she could maybe
she's just not looking because she's so
comfortable in her situation or maybe
she could sleep up
but not lock him down but also um i
don't know a lot of with the whole baby
mama baby daddy why is there so much
drama like from it could be from either
side i feel like there's always
something
like people don't always break up in the
best amicable way well it's because they
didn't plan a family yeah exactly if you
just get pregnant yeah it's not really
like a decision that both of them plan
but there's also a lot of women that try
to trap the man as well which is like
he's not gonna love you just because you
have his child you know well they're
paid to do it
if you pay someone to trap like trap
america you can get child support for 18
years
not in the uk it's not worth it
it's like it's like
it's really low
now it's decent it's like 15
here something like that if someone's
rich that could be a decent chunk of
change and if there's a house involved
then you get to live in it until child's
18.
oh really no
i didn't know that
and that husband gets thrown out on the
street
oh [ __ ] really i didn't actually know
that that's crazy you have kids involved
right yeah yeah
so what is from the ladies what is a guy
that you would settle for
me um
i feel like
if i would settle it would be more so
because of my emotions
um and that would be out of love like if
i genuinely care for that person and
you know sometimes we talk about oh yeah
you know this guy he has so much
potential you know he's going somewhere
i feel like that may be
um a reason for me to settle because of
my emotions oh so it would be like it'd
be like a bomb
no you said he's going somewhere so i'm
assuming he's not somewhere now oh
i'm just based off what you said oh well
you'd be settling for like a guy that's
not financially there i'm you're going
to hold him down
no i i feel like he won't be doing that
i feel as though
i need pain
that was real that wasn't me
no but i feel as though um the
definition is subjective you know like
personally for me when i say potential i
mean okay someone that is going
somewhere with their their life okay
they have a job or they have a secure um
income but their dreams and aspirations
are a lot larger than what they have at
the moment like for me personally i
would never settle for a bomb like
bombing behavior is
no no okay he's gotta he's gonna have a
job i mean he's gotta have like whatever
it needs to be like matching at least
or higher
a job that
he's able to provide for himself and do
things for himself i don't mean like a
bum that's just sitting on the couch
like oh bye honey or welcome home like
so when you say settle so what did you
mean when you said like you're gonna
hold him down and he's gonna no i'm i
just necessarily oh
i just meant in terms of like um holding
that person down i don't believe i said
that because i know personally
no i just mean in in terms of like
supporting that person with their
aspirations i wouldn't hold that man
down like okay that's not how i was
raised
what's the guy that you would settle for
that i would settle for yeah
well a guy that i would settle for has
to be a guy that
has a good job earns good money
um is a family man
um
and yeah i don't know
okay so that sounds like a catch
that doesn't sound like settling
the standards
like that sounds like give me his number
you know
a man with a job
and she said family man yeah great go
ahead with a job who likes pets
um
i'm not sure if i could settle
because like the number one important
the most important thing for me is
character okay and so
kind of an issue i'm having with dating
is like
i date with the intention of marriage
and if i marry then i have to submit
and so i would need somebody in which i
trust their judgment in order to submit
to them
so that's like the number one thing for
me and we need to have the same values
which are what
um preferably the same
outlook in terms of like politics
hopefully religion but it's kind of hard
to find
um and somebody that wants a family
mainly
okay i think it's also worth saying that
you know marriage is a partnership very
much a partnership it may be a
partnership you know at the end of the
day if you have two people
um trying to do something they're
they're going to disagree they're they
are absolutely going to disagree so
somebody has to have the casting vote
yeah and
quite often that's the man quite often
it's the woman as well actually but
um
you know you need to you need to build a
partnership
and practicing building that partnership
in a boyfriend girlfriend situation is a
bloody good idea not just evaluating
them as somebody who you might attach to
yourself
but also
but also
can i build something together with this
person can i make a partnership with
them in
the real sense
you know when you guys are describing
your partners as well is this someone
that you would marry or someone you date
because i feel like because in my
situation right i was i was just a
teacher so like 23k and i was 10k in
debt
right so if i told you those two things
i was a teacher
23k and i was in debt most of you
probably wouldn't like even give me a
chance right and
this is why i like kind of your answer a
bit where you said well as long as
there's like drive or like the idea but
i think the problem is you wouldn't even
date that guy in the first place to find
out if he did have drive or if he did
that
that's how my dad was with my mom like
he he was in a lot of debt when she
first met him
like yo i feel like your situation does
not equal your future like or you know
no i agree i was just saying like yeah
like how do you see that how do you
without being vain or not vain but like
a profile you can't you can't get that
right you can't for me like
it's the more the most important thing
is like morals and like how a person
carries themselves like
how you treat people how you present
yourself that is the top
thing for me the money comes after like
the money is not even a major thing is
because we're all out here chasing goals
chasing dreams we're all not where we
want to be so we're all in our own
little journey i'm doing quite well
speak for yourself
it wasn't overnight
i think it's worth saying that um yes
ambition is
you know
very likely to be in your shopping list
one of the boxes that you tick so to
speak but
the issue is that
um
i'd say feminism has made men less
ambitious
in recent years
yeah it's it's um you know it's put
you know if there's anybody who's who's
uh
who's uh has less attention paid to them
um
it's it's young men
and and they're not encouraged to be
ambitious the thing about ambition is
you have to have
a vision of what you can do what's
possible in your life
and they're being ignored so
you know
finding an ambitious man at this precise
moment in history is not an easy thing
to do
you know
you have to be
i'm not saying it's your responsibility
but what i'm saying is
yeah look for a guy who's got potential
even if he doesn't know exactly where
he's going
look for a guy who's got potential and
bring help him to bring that out in
himself if you can do that and that's
brilliant i think men need purpose too
and it's hard for them when they don't
have a woman to pursue or show any
interest in them and one out of three
men are either virgins or haven't had
sex in the past year
well yeah so i think there's a large
portion of men that's growing that feels
very unseen
and are very lonely and i think and i
think it's like hard to be motivated if
you don't have a woman to work for
absolutely
um
ish do you want to show them
so we're going to watch a video
um this video is by poor man's podcast
shout out um really great channel you
guys should look him up if you haven't
seen his stuff already he does really
great compilation and reaction videos
um
okay so we're gonna look on there
okay
um so this okay yeah
you can put it in the full video
like everyone on the screen yeah
the bare minimum but for men y'all we
have to come with a hundred percent we
have to check off every box but as women
we have to be like you know what he
provides
he he's he's loyal so therefore he
doesn't have to be physically attractive
what what boxes are y'all checking off
let me know what you we try we check off
everything
we are smart we provide we're good wife
we're good mothers
we have good we come from good homes we
can cook we can clean we're good in bed
like everything that we have to
mount up to we do
and i feel like as women
unfortunately we have to settle i'm
gonna take it in the order that you said
because when you ask a question off the
top usually people respond with what's
off the top okay right your first things
that you listed had nothing to do with
what men want and women what do you all
want and that's the problem we want a
feminine woman that wants to be fit that
wants to take care of the small
inconveniences in our lives and
reciprocate the value
so if i go
the inconveniences in my life so for me
for example i go to work every single
day my wife gets to sleep in if she
wants to i have a trip to florida in 10
days she's already booked the trip she's
already booked the flight she's already
taken care of airbnbs i don't have to
worry about that when i get when i sit
down she brings me a warm plate that's
something that i look for in a woman i
don't care about if a woman can provide
but why would a man care about if a
woman can provide do you feel like your
household is the typical household that
we see now in 2021 are are we now in a
atmosphere where it's both women and men
bringing things to the table as far as
providing for a household you say your
wife your wife gets to sleep in okay
that is that's really good yeah but
that's not typical that's but that's
because my wife selected me based on my
drive and not my appearance she seen the
vision she seemed where i wanted to go
and she helped me get to that position
so she ain't women do that why do we get
called gold diggers do you feel like
your wife was a gold digger because she
looked at your drive she looked at your
ambition she looked at what you could do
for her financially my wife was with me
since i was 15. so that in particular
i'm gonna get out you know because
that's not the typical situation what
i'm trying to get at i don't
if a woman is kind of the gold digger if
the man already is solidified and that's
what women want in 2021 and that's why
it don't work out y'all try to go for
men that are already solidified that
look a certain kind of way and then when
it don't work out y'all play dumb look
at it look at brittany renner pj
washington dealing with pj washington oh
he told me this he told me that that
don't matter did he put a ring on that
finger we judge a character based off
action we judge characters they were
married we judged character based on
actions they were married so i was
confused pj dj watched it brittany ryan
was married yes oh [ __ ] i [ __ ] that up
but you looking at like situations like
sierra and future look at their
situation you dealing with a man that's
been around the block he got kids he
ain't been taking care of his kids and
now you want to lay up with him and this
ain't even something that's celebrity
only reason i use celebrities is because
we all know them people i can go to the
hood right now to show you hella
relationships that's messed up because
it's a dude that's a crackhead he got
three or four baby moments he ain't
doing nothing with his life but because
he looked a certain way all these women
want to lay up with him and date them
based on potential
but when you're talking about potential
are you talking about will smith before
he became will smith because that's
potential are you talking about barack
obama when michelle obama held him down
through law school because that's
potential but are you talking about a
dude that's just sexually attractive
that ain't doing that with his life are
you hoping that he get it together one
day while he living off of your uh your
refund check i feel like that's easier
said than done like you said you want
women to go you're telling me women
should date based off potential but as
soon as we do that we get called every
negative name in the book if we look at
a man and say hey he has a good job
he can financially provide for me he
might not be the best looking but i look
good we automatically get labeled a gold
digger
but you're telling me that's what we
should be going after but i'm but you're
also saying that look at brittany renner
she went she went after a guy that could
financially provide for he for her he
might not have been the best guy but she
thought would you consider brittany a
gold digger
uh i would consider opportunist
for sure and i think that her resume
shows that and i think that that's why
she's catching the flag she's catching
the flag because she promoted herself
and branded herself as a woman that
would go after men for a check why can't
we go based off potential and
opportunity you can go based off of
potential opportunity but the problem is
y'all not going off potentially an
opportunity y'all going off of men
they're already successful that's the
problem there's nothing wrong with that
you have to look at the age that we're
dating at this point there are people
becoming more successful younger and
younger we're not talking about these
people that are becoming successful in
their 50s and 60s people are coming
becoming millionaires and they're young
that's instagram that's the difference
in perspective men don't reach financial
potential the peak of their financial
potential until about 55 to 65 years old
that's not always true though it's not
always true but see now we're going to
the exceptions but you don't know who i
date what if i date the exception we
going to the exception what if i date
the exception but you don't because if
you was dating the acceptance you would
still be with them
who said that not with them
okay maybe that's fair okay what i'm
basically getting at is women are
looking for the wrong name me one good
king one good conqueror that had one
woman
lebron
you think lebron i got one i'm an
athlete i'm an ex professional athlete
come on let's keep it a book you think
lebron ain't
and i'm not even going and you can't
even count martin luther king because he
was sleeping around he was right so what
are we talking about any good man that
has already been established come on
let's just keep it i'm just thinking
didn't we just discuss that if you text
everybody on your phone right now
you you said 100 success rate would
sleep with you
that's not the case for average men do
you know that 30 of men will be virgins
by the age of 30 will have never touched
a woman
that means that women have the selective
choice of who they mate with so you have
the responsibility of who a lot who you
allowing your body y'all choosing them
based off appearance that's what i'm
trying to get at when y'all got the
whole y'all got the y'all got a layout
all you got to do as a woman is okay so
for men our burden to society our burden
to humanity is to
build civilizations that's our job
whatever you want i'ma provide men build
the microphone build the camera build
the house this is all men this is what
we do we provide
you gonna make the face like we don't do
that
this is what we do we provide locally
women have
started things
first a lot of the time but it's okay go
ahead
the reason why i feel like it is men
because
i feel like men have too many options
i feel like
men kinda are at this point like they
find something good
but they're never satisfied
so whenever they feel like something
else comes to them that might be a
little bit better unfortunately they hop
on that and they take that next option
so so when i just said the statistic
that 30 of men would be virgins that
didn't like do anything that didn't
think that didn't show to you that men
don't by and large have the majority of
the options men get what
men get with what they can get women get
to choose who they want when it comes to
sexual i feel like virgins can be not
[ __ ] too
so no so everybody in your phone that
you get to choose from
oh you can wait until you're done with
the sentence those are all men that are
in your plethora of people you can be
involved with now it's up for you to
decide whether those men are good
candidates for you to be involved with
now that's your responsibility as a
woman like i said a man's responsibility
is to build civilizations and societies
a woman's responsibility is to br to
bring forth the next generation of
society builders
okay
so i'd like to get everyone's thoughts
on that clip
me phil here go ahead so much so much
came out honestly
one thing was
that um you know
okay
oh i'm sorry i you know obviously i'm
i'm talking from the perspective of
somebody who's uh you know quite a long
way from his puberty so you know i've
seen the dating
landscape change quite dramatically in
my life
and one or two things kind of came up
one of the things was that
not so much in the uk but certainly in
america it was
you didn't date somebody unless your dad
had
given him the once over
you know you just didn't
maybe you disagree are you saying that
sierra's dad wouldn't have approved a
future
i don't know
maybe he would who knows but but no i
mean the the
in the states it was like the first
thing that happened there was a
a trope of you know the boyfriend
knocking on the front door and the
father opened uh you know
answering it
and
you know she's agonizing over oh i need
to make all these choices well the dad
used to do the first level of filtering
you know a few a couple of decades ago
there was also the fact that it's like
actually do you know what the idea of a
woman
finding a man's body attractive is
relatively new as well i mean i remember
i don't know when i was in my early 20s
maybe when women started started going
oh he's got a nice bum before that
it was of no
importance whatsoever whether a guy was
whether guy's body was sexually
attractive or not
so like did girls just not care about
looks at all it was more about character
it was much more about connection
because women are supposed to be the
attractive ones yes it's really supposed
to be the matter
let's face it we're not actually i mean
you know maybe 0.5 of men is really
actually women find 80 of men
unattractive yeah
not not just okay unattractive yeah yeah
yeah so yeah i mean that you know pretty
much pans out yeah
like just to to your stat like all the
people that i know in relationships have
all been from like in work friend of a
friend stuff like that the tinder thing
just hasn't worked for guys by the way
the tinder thing just hasn't worked
actually even my female friends well
yeah women women only swipe right like 5
to 15 of the time on dating apps and
that's the number one way people are
meeting nowadays so the reason that
women say things like men are trash is
because they're all screwing the same
ones
you guys yeah i mean i would say the
only thing i don't agree with that like
a lot of it like made sense the only
thing is like when he said what he looks
for in a woman that the the only thing
is like i do want a female i'm dating to
at least have a job because if she was
23 and didn't have a job that would just
be a little bit weird and you you gotta
take the economic like uh thing in this
like the average wage is like 28 grand
right and and you can't live off that on
your own so usually you expect you and
your partner to have a job so if she
doesn't then all the burdens on you so i
just think
in modern day you kind of have to not
she doesn't have to be the provider but
you at least want her to bring
uh something
it probably mitigates risk a little bit
if people are more successful
but i think the point is like you're not
if a girl has a high paying job you're
not like oh that's hot yeah
where if a guy has a high paying job
we're like oh damn yeah yeah so that's
more like a minimum i at least want them
to have a job but i don't care if
they're whatever
i think it's worth it
because i think it's worth pointing out
that i mean so for instance
i lived in a house with one income my
father's income
my mum looked after me and my brother so
she could dedicate all of her time to us
yeah
feminism rolls along all of a sudden
it's better to have a boss than a
husband
you know that was basically the message
of feminism isn't it and uh and
basically
uh
families had two incomes
uh and the house prices and prices of
everything else rose to accommodate that
they got dinkies double income no kids
yeah
which which were like the uh the
you know newly married couple and then
and then essentially everything
everything became more difficult because
all of a sudden you needed two income
you needed two incomes to be able to get
a mortgage you needed two incomes to be
able to afford a holiday
um and that was the sum total of the
effect of of feminism other than the
fact that of course the government got
twice as much tax but tax money
you know
and the children got neglected as a
result
i think it also depends on the lifestyle
you want to like if you want to live in
a city like london yes two incomes is
necessary but if you want to live in a
rural side
where the home prices are significantly
cheaper
if perhaps you want to homeschool your
children grow your own food i think it's
definitely possible depending on what
your priorities are
but yeah it depends on the couple what
did you guys think of the clip i feel
like those comments are based on like
basic gender roles like things are not
it's it's not um it doesn't match what's
happening in today's world
um he's saying oh
women are only going for successful guys
but women have literally been taught
from a young age to go for a guy that's
stable that has a good job not just by
their mothers by their fathers too
because no dad would accept a guy who
doesn't have a [ __ ] together let's say
so well i think i think that women um
are told from a young age they don't
need a man
and you can you you can be your own boss
and chase the bag
as well yeah yeah so i don't really find
the ends yeah yeah i don't really find
that like um
at least under a certain age i don't see
women chasing the guys with like
that are like driven and hardworking and
like good men i see them chasing more of
like the bad boys
yeah i think a lot of women or
these days now are going for a lot of
like image yeah guys that drive nice
cars guys
that have money and have maybe because
it's social media and this whole thing
of looking a certain way
um if you drive this you have this i
feel like women are now going for that
that's probably why they do end up
with men that are just
[ __ ] because these men don't actually
have personality it's just all the front
basically and they'll rather put up with
that if it means they're sitting in a
nice car and they're going to the nicest
restaurants like you said novokov
they'll rather put up with that then i
guess that's the bear meant that they'll
rather have that bare minimum if it
means that they look good doing it
but then also like pearl said like um
men are intimidated by successful women
so i didn't say they were intimidated no
they i'm not them all i don't know i
don't i don't think so i don't think
about care
i think they do a lot of men have this
ego thing i think they're only
intimidated by women that throw their
money in their face
so like i don't i don't think um like i
i don't think most men are intimidated
by women that have a lot of money it's
more than women that think they're
better than everyone else and it's not
really that they're intimidated they
just don't like them or want to deal
with them because they think they're
better than everyone else two 200 000
engagement ring
but yeah but then don't the men carry
themselves like that as well when they
have money it's the same well i think
they just carry themselves like they're
the prize because they are
i think it definitely is ego they can
feel a bit intimidated you know if their
their wife is earning a lot of money and
then
she wants a certain thing and he can't
provide it for her that that could like
hit his ego and make him but i think i
think that's the point though like so a
girl will like the girl will don't
doesn't mind ego right if someone's
quite uh they're like confident stuff
like that showy but then when a female
is very ego driven right that's
off-putting to a lot of men because
that isn't you know like you said were
like oh well why shouldn't i like
they've got money they've made their own
money and it's just like
we don't really care like like type
things so it's not a very mothery thing
to be yeah and it's not really don't
care because don't get me wrong like if
i had the same girl and one one earned
more and one earn less of course i'm
gonna go for the one who earned more but
that's not the that's not a deciding
like if you had a chart of like a game
chart with all these like stats that's
not the deciding factor it's really low
on the scale
but i think it's because a lot of times
women like we think like women and so we
think that men want the things we want
but they they just don't care
it's like it's it's like um have you
ever
had a guy have like a really cool shoe
collection
do you care
okay she cares
i think it was interesting i'm sorry too
um one one other thing that came up was
it was the uh you know it dawned upon me
that
you know there are
there are couples where the uh where the
the man's successful and the woman isn't
and there are couples where both of them
are successful they're very very very
few
uh couples where the woman's successful
and the husband isn't
you know there's a you know
there's this kind of
trope of the of the the power couple
but um
you know
it just very very seldom happens and the
relationship needs to be incredibly
strong to sustain that as well
would you guys um find a guy attractive
if he made less money than you
significantly
would that matter to you
not really to be honest i don't think
that equates to attraction yeah because
like yeah you might earn less but do you
know how do you know how to carry
yourself i feel like that's most
important there's so many other boxes to
tick would that question change if they
were older so say if they're 35
and they earn less than you
would your answer change
mine would
that's questionable yeah yeah because
it's a lot
i know like
for us as women sometimes we look at
like older men as like okay they're a
lot older than us or they are older than
us they've accomplished a lot more
because they've been on the planet um
for a longer period of time but then if
they haven't got a job or not earning as
much then it's like okay what have you
been doing all of this time at your big
age it just it doesn't really i don't
know it's hard
it's harder because you don't know
people's you know stories or backgrounds
yeah i i mean that just shows though
that like you are looking for money in a
way it might not be like that thing but
because they've reached a certain age
where you think they're not going to
earn any more money than this so it
doesn't mean you do matter about it i
feel it i feel personally for me it's
more an opinion of like what my parents
and what their expectations of me are
especially like obviously being a woman
living in a patriarchal society like a
lot of things are not really geared
towards women's safety or women being
able to earn as much money as men or um
being able to reach high ceo positions
what are you talking about our whole
society is geared towards women women
make 70 to 80 of consumer buying
decisions our whole media is geared
towards women empowerment there's no
men's empowerment okay well i i don't
know the statistics so i'm definitely
wrong here but i'm just saying in terms
of like um
you know
um maybe more so traditional values then
and the way that like women um see men
as
a way
a type of security or like a safety net
so to speak so when i'm looking at it
from kind of that perspective if we're
really looking at a man that is the
example 35 who's earning a lot less than
a female that is a lot younger then for
me personally would be questionable
because then bringing that home to my
family and my family's like okay so
you're a young woman how is your
potential husband going to be able to
look after you and not only you but your
children do you think it's fair to ask
men to provide traditional outcomes when
we're not traditional no no
it depends on um the couple like uh the
the couple has to be compatible together
and it depends on whether they um
consider or value societal values in
their relationship no so i'm just saying
like by and large like i know there's
going to be new you know what i mean i
know there's going to be nuance but i'm
saying like by and large do you think
it's fair to to ask for traditional
outcomes when we're not traditional
women anymore
what is your definition of interest so
not being a traditional woman anymore so
i would say if you're not a virgin like
you're not a traditional woman
because a traditional woman like
traditionally women were virgins when
they got married
and a traditional outcome is when the
man is still expected to protect and
provide
so it's like we're asking for
traditional outcomes when we're not
traditional ourselves yeah because even
in your situation you were a bit
traditional yourself there because when
you answer that you you worry about what
your family's gonna think then why
couldn't you be the provider like if you
truly felt that way why can't you that
it doesn't matter if the man's a nurse
and earning like 20k or whatever why
couldn't you be the big you know the
main thing so even in yourself your
answer is a bit
uh traditional yeah i i guess so i feel
like that's maybe because i value like
my parents opinion but then also i
wouldn't want to be a provider like i
feel as though sometimes
women they take on this big struggle of
yeah i have to do everything
or they don't necessarily have the
support of like men um in order to like
reach their goals and aspirations and
they're looking after everyone else but
themselves so it's just like oh i
personally i wouldn't prefer to like be
like the main earner in my household
like i want to put my feet up i want to
relax like the struggle life is not for
me
i don't know
yeah the traditional ways like men want
the same as we do like you want to be
cleaned
cooked for being taken care of so would
you say modern women by and large offer
that because they also want purity in
youth and we don't offer either of those
things purity i don't think is really a
major thing to be honest because where
we women really pure back then we don't
know a hundred percent yeah so they say
yeah we can't guarantee that i have a
question for the men would you want a
girl that slept with a hundred people no
would you want a girl that slept with
100 no but my answer is probably
different to what you expect like
because my reason is just like i don't
actually care that it's 100 people
it's just the fact that i wouldn't go
for that type of girl who is willing to
sleep with 100 people so it's not the
number that puts me off it's just then i
know that's that type of person like to
act but then you're basing her off the
number right well it's based off it's
based off of choices that she makes yeah
so like it's like if i was looking at a
guy and he cheated on every single girl
he'd been with like i could infer that
he's a cheater so if a girl's been
sleeping around for the past decade he
can infer she's a hoe not exactly like
your your body count does not amount to
who you are
well people do change as well yeah but
it amounts to your decision-making
abilities
but then that deter that those decision
abilities may be determined because of
like childhood trauma
or like things that that person has gone
through or experienced or experienced
like a true negative that's true
experience but the world doesn't owe you
understanding
yeah so so the guy
the guy like when you come to a guy he
doesn't owe you understanding and if you
come to him and he can tell you slipped
around like i think it's in his right to
not want to date you then i have a
question do you think that a male like
for us being women do you think
men owe us respect
um i mean i think everyone deserves like
a basic
level of like
i don't even want to say respects i
guess respect is earned but like human
decency
but i think like you should be selective
in who you date and i think men have a
right to be selective in who they date
and if they don't want to date a girl
that's slept around i think that's
perfectly fine and i wouldn't want my
brother to date a girl that's like
banging the whole football team
at double standards because the male can
bang the whole cheerleading
because a man has to become something in
order to sleep around
he you're not gonna you're not gonna
okay you're not gonna sleep around with
like an overweight bum
right
you forgot overweight bum comes up to
you you going on a date with him
i don't know it depends on the
confidence
[Laughter]
well okay but but if we look at the data
the results speak for themselves one out
of three men are either virgins or
heaven at sex in the past year
so we don't owe them sex or
understanding for not being able to get
laid
just and that's the same way like men
don't owe us relationships if we've
slept around it makes me laugh as well
because if an ugly person comes up to
you in a club and gives you a compliment
or say something nice it comes across as
creepy yeah right that guy's a creep if
a handsome person or a good looking
person comes up to you you're flirting
like shy and stuff like that you know so
it it it depends on the person who says
it's really i think that's right also
the equivalent to
men sleeping around not being fez
men saying oh like if i'm broke should
you still date me
so like women go for guys that are
established financially or that's what
they want even if they're looking
potential wise they won't date a
good-looking bomb
for
too long it won't be long term okay so
what the saying you can't turn a hoe
into a housewife but how many hoes are
housewives right now
yeah you're right you're right i i
i actually agree with you to some level
like those girls do usually still get
married the problem is they leave they
get bored and statistically the data
supports that because a woman that's had
sex with more with that's a virgin when
she gets married has an 80 chance of
happy marriage and if she has sex with
more than five people which most men
pray for nowadays it goes down it goes
down to like 25 percent is that a happy
marriage or is that settling we don't
what do you what do you mean like that
the woman that was a virgin and then
married like well you don't know how
good her sex life is well
you ask her if she's happy in her
marriage and there's 80 chance after 10
years she says yes i'm happy where the
girl that's had sex with more than five
people there's a 25 chance that she says
yes i'm happy so if i'm a dude and i'm
thinking hmm do i want to go with more
bodies or less bodies i'd pick less
bodies but that's because that's all she
knows isn't it like that's that's that's
all she the only person she is so that's
what she's going to be happy with if
you've tried and tested around and
obviously you know you're right that's
correct like the more you have to
compare it to but it's like
guys don't want to be compared to a
whole bunch of dudes that's not
attractive
what's wrong with
with being satisfied i mean
you know you're saying oh well i'm gonna
gotta go and test drive a whole lot of
cars before you decide which one you
want to spend the rest of your life with
but there again if something somebody
just gave you a car
you'd be happy with it
and and and isn't that in at the end of
the day isn't that the objective to be
happy
yeah yeah so yeah but everyone if you
know there was a there was an old song
in the 60s
if you can't be with the one you love be
the love the one you're with
yeah people haven't
people have this no it's not it's not
separate the thing is the only reason
why you think it's happening is because
disney is yeah
disney has convinced you that you're
somehow or another you're you're you
know you're a princess that that
deserves to have a prince and the
numbers of princes are very very low
well
and the issue is you have girls that are
fours fives and sixes sleeping with
eights nines and tens and they think
they're on that level and so when they
actually meet the guy that's going to
marry them and is at their level that'll
put a ring on it they think they're
settling but they're not settling your
level's what you can get
they're dating up then
there's their women sleep up
yeah
and then the data and you can you we
have more data on this than ever because
we have dating app data which is
extremely honest so it says what what do
women want and it's between five to
fifteen percent of guys they're screwing
all the girls i mean i went to um a
pickup artist boot camp which is
yeah i did this for a youtube video
where it's like basically a camp where
these guys teach other guys how to get
laid and they'll teach them things like
for example the girl's not gonna want to
sleep with you if you haven't touched
her the whole date and that's something
you wouldn't really think about as a
woman like you know they touch your arm
touch your back that like builds
attraction and
um like one of the dudes that was um
like teaching the camp i literally saw
him take home four girls in four days
and none of those girls were that cute
but it's like those guys are literally
sleeping with everybody i'm i'm
surprised because i would have said if
you have to go to a pickup class to get
girls
he was the instructor
he wasn't the one
if you want to make a dollar
oh my
it was like oh my god they they spend a
lot of money on that camp so if any if
you ever want a business i pick up i'm
just interested why there were so many
girls at the men's pickup no it was just
me it wasn't a lot of girls it was oh
you mean no it was basically like they
would okay all these guys would fly to
vegas
and then at vegas they would
teach them how to get laid at like the
clubs and stuff so i did it as like a
vlog this is like i don't know you
probably find it on my channel like six
months to a year ago
um yeah and i just wanted to see like
it's kind of like nosy like what are the
guys talking about
that
question is like
because we live in a really
hyper-sexualized culture
like
i know like
i talked to my girlfriends and stuff and
they blatantly lie about how many guys
they've had sex with but a lot of guys
don't want virgins either
so it's like it's kind of a no-win
situation
yeah i mean i think virgins have a hard
time too because the guys that are
sleeping with everybody like they don't
want to wait either yeah that's fine
yeah um but on the other end
you know what's weird i've actually
asked guys a lot about this
they say like 10 is the number that's
too high but they'd like prefer someone
around like five like three to five
seems to be like the magic
yeah but then they just lie about it
yeah but that's the thing like i i don't
think
it hurts the women themselves because
it's in their head they're the ones that
are going to be comparing that's why i
say like like hoes get wifed i think
every girl in this room like we can all
think of a hoe
that her boyfriend has no idea what she
used to do right
yeah yeah and and the problem is they
leave
yeah i don't i don't have a solution for
you i wish i wish it does hurt women a
lot when they sleep around though yeah
because then they can't really bond yeah
yeah it's very difficult to do that
unless it's like
the most desired guy
it's like in the one percent of guys
yeah no that's that's the problem with
it is um
yeah it's like
it's the more guys you sleep with the
more you have to compare it to and the
more like the one you end up with isn't
going to measure up
sorry someone was going to say something
yeah but it's more than just that i
would say you know there's a whole
package
um
collaborate
elaborate it's the whole package it's
not just you know how good they are in
bed
for who
for the woman
because you're saying that she would get
bored and then obviously leave if cause
she slept around and had other men that
i'm saying
it's more it's more than just you know
just sleeping together you're right i
mean women compare in more than one way
but i don't think that makes it better
if anything that makes it worse
because you'll think oh that guy had
money that guy had muscles
i mean imagine if men said oh she's not
a victorious secret model
so i'm settling
oh her stomach isn't like perfect yeah
but most guys are like if she's hot
enough nice enough i'll take her
god you know so well
okay i'm gonna read super chats real
quick um
okay guys also um like the video the
like is the most important metric that
you can do to help youtube push out
these videos and the algorithm while
you're at it subscribe to the channel
i'm so tired i'm so tired of y'all
watching these videos and not
subscribing i know some of you will give
me heat in the chat because i put it on
subscribers only but a subscribe is free
okay it is free subscribe to the channel
um also
okay so drasean gaming the average man
can physically harm you anytime he wants
why would i be intimidated when i'm told
to hold back by society what are you on
billy boy i was a virgin when i got
married by choice my wife was not it has
made a relationship very difficult it
has been eight years my wife has since
told her sister to stay a virgin mgtow
by logic panel just be honest please the
homeless population is like 90 percent
male because women can find someone to
pay their bills stop lying women don't
date bums it's fine just don't lie about
it
eli for ish's hat collection which is
wait for isha's hat hat collection when
some is
blue in oh
you're getting a hat collection
i'm starting a hat collection you will
see on the channel every time i'm on
different hats yeah donate to that guys
make sure you super chatting for it help
me
the the uk economist great new studio
pearl thank you everyone clap yay
new studio
um please ask if they're open
oh i'm gonna ask this after the break
okay
um chris girl in the yellow oh this is a
hundred dollar super chat
class
let's go girl girl in the yellow i'm 38
and i make 100k a month you don't
intimidate me or my colleagues saying
that men are intimidated by you is how
you cope with the fact that high net
worth men don't want you for a serious
relationship learn to be more self-aware
you sound delusional
sidney jacob hello from new zealand love
the show i introduced it to my ex to
help her become more feminine love you
pearl the benevolent benevolent patriot
patriarch
these ladies level of cap is over nine
thousand um beans no man would date a
woman like a feminist but
you can say you don't need a man but to
become more valuable you need to be
appreciated but the way you're acting
you're just depreciating 90 free-to-pay
please ask when do women love men as
they are
mgtow by logic men also date on
potential which is also never delivered
and when it's almost always revoked
90 free topay
get new skin toner face looks green
green pants
alistar horton wow the woman's ego in
the video is more inflated than the
american economy um
mgtow by logic women define settling as
anything below perfection which is just
stupid but ruin your life if you want i
don't care my life is great j yeah uncle
berry speaks like my dad but if he was
white i love how respectful the young
guests are quiet and respectful when the
elder statesman speaks stoic masculinity
will women settle more they settle for
being one of many instead of being the
one 90 free topay ninja you might not
know it but there's a ninja on set
daniel a is it really settling when it's
what you can get surely you are on the
same level when it comes to value
lazarus um how did you all get
kakisha on the show
um asian fresh um great setup pearl jc
can you ask moon knight when season two
comes out mgtow by logic if women
settled divorce would nearly be nearly
non-existent men settle way more it's so
lopsided it's actually a trick question
stoic masculinity women don't settle
they just date outside of their league
and then wind up with men on their level
desmond um they are delusional men
settle more we're simple um
say tick news network pearl rocks and
has my respect for leaving her corporate
life to raise awareness on these key um
psycho social subject matters
playboy
lotate
pearl got that new studio congrats um
speak the gospel for men let the 304s
understand their actions and reactions
men don't wipe hoes mgtow by logic the
average average modern woman is fatter
lazier and less feminine than they have
ever been in all of human history men
are the ones settling not women
hypergamy requires it it's math
alexander way boss hogg says big up on
the west gate massive
rob burns pearl fresh and fitter coming
to the uk they're looking for an embassy
it should be you considering um alistar
horton how are you settling into the new
place silly sausage it is harder to be a
sperm donor than it is to get into
harvard height requirement of five eight
or five ten lesbians who don't need men
still won't select 80 of men spurring
sperm bank won't even make donations if
you are short
okay i think that's all of them i'm
going to refresh it really quick and
just double check like the video while
i'm doing that also subscribe to the
channel ring the notification bell that
way you're going to be notified every
time we are live hero that one girl said
that guys don't want virgins i have
never heard a guy say man i would have
dated her but she's a virgin
fabio chan name i like the video just
because you're getting better at reading
super chats
thank you i i appreciate y'all noticing
the improvement the improvement um 90
free tope should women still wear white
at their wedding oh god
the average man oh that's the one we did
already okay
so this was actually a super chat this
is for the ladies
um
so were you saying
you don't think body count matters like
by and large
yeah yeah not really so everyone no one
tells the actual number okay everyone
lies about it
cap okay okay so question will you say
your body count then since it doesn't
matter
it doesn't it doesn't matter right it's
less than five
cap
cap
okay what if i what about you guys what
was the question
why don't you just say it it's less than
five okay so what what's the exact
number four four okay what about you
guys body counts
the only reason i say this is because
like if what if it does if it really
doesn't matter why doesn't everyone just
tell each other yeah i feel like they
should be more open about why is it cap
when a woman
why are you guys saying this cap when a
woman says
that is this on one hand
is that not a real thing anymore
um it was just because there's not many
virgins around me
because men always seem to think that
women are lying about their body can't i
don't understand
why why would we be laughing about our
body counts
can you say that again sorry women lie
about their body camp because they don't
want to reveal their true nature
really yeah so if
a woman is a [ __ ] whole she's gonna
keep that
literally hidden she doesn't want nobody
to know that she's a whole yeah the
streets are talking the streets all know
do you think do you think you can tell
though like like because example if i
meet a girl in a club i'm i'm more like
and they're like
they seem like that type of person but
if i meet a girl in the library who's
never been to a club before i'm gonna
probably believe her body count over
someone who like you like you can kind
of tell i'm not saying in general but
the the way girls act if they're
confident bubbly stuff like that like
you what are you what do you guys think
because i i think girls know more behind
the scenes than guys do like we hear
more we know more do you think guys can
tell
no no
no they think they do they can't tell
because they're already saying kaplan is
already wrong
same way they can't tell when their girl
is cheating the same way they can't tell
someone
they're saying
well you're speaking from experience
not my portion
is it was there someone you know that
that happened with what happened i want
to be in the know you're laughing
i'm just saying there's a lot of girls
out there that move mad
they have men at home
their men don't know
they don't know do you think that
they're cheating because they married or
in a relationship with their second
choice and it wasn't who they really
wanted i feel like um when it comes to
relationships people um
lose that drive when the years like
start to pile up
people stop being like as affectionate
as romantic like going that extra mile i
think that's what drives people apart
and maybe that's when one person might
step out you think women get bored
and then she i feel like if you get
bored then you haven't picked the right
person
or maybe it could be attention like
you're like the person someone else is
giving you more attention than your
partner which you don't know that could
but why are you turning your your eye in
the first
place something is happening yeah yeah
but it's tiring like i'm not gonna lie
like even like i'm married and happily
married but like it's tiring just like
my wife puts on makeup or puts on a
dress and if i don't say anything like
anything at all then that's it a mood's
ruined right so it's like i have to
comment because they've made an effort
but to me it's like i don't care but is
it maybe because you didn't compliment
her enough when you guys were dating or
but that that's what i mean like it's
like and guys just don't express it as
much maybe that i'm thinking it in my
head but i'm not gonna say it like it's
just but you're quick to go unlike
someone like a girl's picture on
instagram i mean i don't do that so i
can't speak for all guys
but i don't do that because i i just
find that i find that action a bit weird
like going on instagram looking at other
girls and then liking them or like say
if like a lot of guys these days watch a
lot of twitch streamers like the female
twitch streamers yeah and i feel like if
you had a partner that is
to me a little bit weird if you had a
partner like well it depends why you're
watching the twitch stream of course but
for me i it just feels a little icky
well i think like women
they are very difficult to satisfy which
is why
um what was it body count you said body
count
which is why that's so important so that
they can connect to their husband
um
yeah i think that's it and i also
understand your point when you were
saying how they were sleeping with guys
that are like tens and nines when
they're like not
because it just like
they want that but they can't attain it
yeah and that's why i think like a lot
of girls think they're settling but it's
just their level your level's what you
can get to commit to you
hmm otherwise it's out of your life
before
yeah i mean
guys levels who they can get to sleep
with them girls level is who they can
get to commit to them
if you can't get him to commit if he
doesn't want to be with you that's not
your level
and just to add on that right
you said something me yeah you you said
you said ah
when i'm par corrected you said date
when we were talking about guys sleeping
with them and it was the idea that most
girls
have it in their minds that the tens
that they're [ __ ] let's say if there
are six
they're actually dating them
but in fact you're actually just
sleeping with him
and so most girls have it like oh i'm
dating that guy
but really you're not
and that's the delusion that we're
trying to point out that a lot of women
who are [ __ ] the tens who are
actually sixes
are not understanding that that's not
their level because they think they're
dating them but really they're just
sleeping with them yeah because i would
also say those guys at the top level if
you are high value man or whatever you
want to call it
they have more choice so like you're not
the only pretty girl going for them
right so then they actually are looking
for other things because they have a ton
of pretty girls going for them and
whereas the girl probably thinks in that
situation oh i'm a cat i got i got this
guy stuff like that but but i from my
experience
the the people who who are high earners
they if they do get a lot of girls
anyway that they're actually more picky
on who they who they want so why do so
many like ugly guys have such a high
body count if that's the case
but it's not true is it because they
don't have money
money no they're not actually ugly
that's the thing
you you think they're ugly because women
find 80 of men unattractive
but
it's the same with like ugly girls as
well like how how i come it's so easy
for them to get the guy that's the 10.
well yeah
it depends there's a couple dynamics
that i see if the guys attend like
usually she has other qualities
uh oh is he dating her sleeping with her
no just sleeping together oh well guys
will sleep with anything
in bed that's something yeah guys guys
will sleep with girls they would never
be seen in public with ever yeah and you
see people cheat with uglier girls like
they might have a banging one why does
that happen yeah yeah you got you gotta
worry about the ugly girls too you gotta
worry oh that's your baby mom
explain it no it's men men are looking
to qualify where women are looking to
disqualify so like if you're going on a
date with a guy you're thinking like i
have these requirements and let me see
if he meets them where men are like oh
is she hot enough good enough
is she nice enough oh that's maybe not
nice enough to date but tonight that's
yeah good enough
because men men swipe right on dating
apps around 50 of the time so they find
roughly 50 of women attractive where
women only find five to maybe 20 on the
high end percent of guys attractive
wow
so
yeah yeah and the guys you know you said
ugly guys aren't but the thing is ugly
guys just aren't getting anything at all
those are the people you're even
acknowledging the people that you're
even talking to there's a lot of guys
that are just at home all day that they
just like do whatever they're doing that
that you don't even see so so it's in
your circle of guys that you're like oh
this guy's ugly but it's leaving people
but then that's why one in three are
what would you say one in three are like
virgins or something like that but
someone might find them attractive just
because they're ugly to somebody
and on top of that maybe you're right
you said that they're sitting at home
that's probably why they're not they're
not [ __ ] because no one can see them
they're not visible to the world
but then if someone if someone if
someone found them attractive they'd be
[ __ ]
yeah at home all day then they're not
going to be they're not gonna they might
have co it might be confidence as well
women want a confident man if you're not
approaching me and that that could be
you could not be confident enough which
is why you're not able to get to that
level you could be next to a girl maybe
you're not confident enough to put it on
her and start something okay imagine if
you went up to 50 guys and hit on him
and all of them said no
would you be confident
yeah that would be like yeah and that's
and the thing is like even even when i
when i went to that pickup artist boot
camp i i understood like men on a
different level because they'd be decent
looking guys and the amount of rejection
they would have to go through to find
one girl that would be even remotely
interested and this was at a bar where
they're drunk where the odds are in
their favor was like crazy to me
like guys have to go through so much
rejection to get laid that
that honestly if they get enough
rejection i can understand why they just
want to stop trying
yeah i mean i would i would back up your
point a tiny bit because um
uh one of my exes i let her leave her
profile open because i found it
interesting reading
what messages guys
like you know would send and some of
like
50 or 50 percent of them are just like
creepy or like seriously creepy or weird
or just you know
a d-pick or whatever like out of nowhere
so i'll give you that for for that bit
but yeah like pearl said with the other
the other half
okay next question
do you guys think people deserve love
everyone deserves love absolutely not
type of [ __ ]
okay okay so you say no why no it's it's
something you earn love is very special
it's sacred
it shouldn't just be given to anybody
because it wouldn't have value if you if
you're grumpy if you're rude if you
don't do anything
what what is there what is there to
admire about you
okay what do you got you guys said yes i
said everyone deserves love in a sense
where you know someone needs to be loved
by someone whether that's your mom or
your dad that's loving you
like they need love but in terms of like
me giving love to someone then yeah not
everyone can just get my love because my
love isn't something that i'll just be
throwing out i'm very like protective of
it
for me i also agree with you i'm don't
remember your name um yeah not everyone
deserves love because some people are
just too evil too wicked too spiteful
and they don't have pure or good
intentions or they try to manipulate you
or deceive you or like love for me and
then
change into a completely different
person so no not everyone deserves love
um so i i kind of half agree with the
thingy like love in a relationship
no but loving a family i think it should
be but at the same time that's more like
responsibility than than actual love
because there are parents out there who
generally just don't love their kids so
it's not it's not um what's it called i
don't know that word where it's like you
have to do it or whatever but yeah so i
would say no in relationships
yeah um
does everyone deserve love no but people
do everyone deserves acknowledgement and
like just
making you feel like you exist to
someone
like it doesn't have to be full on love
but at least appreciation
do you feel like homeless men are
appreciated
some of them i've seen some of them
maybe by and large like
in general
they probably were at some point in time
yeah you think so
yeah i i'd say exceptional like vets or
something like that but but other than
that
it's really hard to look like oh this
person doesn't pay money into the tax
system this person doesn't you know that
like it's it's very hard to look at him
it's cruel i'm not saying that you
should but i think general people just
walk past and think like what are you
doing well i think when you say
acknowledgement it's from a woman's
point of view because we're used to
getting attention we've gotten attention
from like the what the day we're like 13
14 whenever you started to like become
womanly but like there's a large portion
of men that like don't get attention
ever
um i wouldn't say just like from being a
woman i would just say just
like being human in general because like
the word the world has become very like
focused on image and social media where
people have lost a sense of humanity so
in that sense well no i i understand
what you're saying but i just think it's
not reality like if you walk past a
homeless man you're not going to give
him any attention or pay him any mind in
general you might give him some change
or food
you might even a look is an
acknowledgement
like you just you looking away and
acting like you don't see that person
then that's you just you don't care
basically okay what do you think
um
in relationships yeah love doesn't
really work but for family love is very
important
quick question as well yeah um so um
i've got your name dionte dionte just
repeat what you said um about spiteful
um i don't even remember but i said
about the most people deserve love
you're like no yeah like some some
people
they're spiteful or wicked like they
they don't have good intentions in their
heart or they go out to destroy other
people because of their past experiences
or because of their trauma or because of
they've been hurt by a female or family
member or whatever else and in order for
them to move forward they don't move
forward with like their best foot or i
was going to say isn't that like a lot
of girls
i i just see baby mom
blab to my head right now really
can you can you um give like expand that
because i don't really understand yeah
like the point of view that you're about
for manipulative yeah all these other
negative words yeah and when when you
say these words i think about a lot of
women it's like you said women have sex
trauma um women get sparked because men
treat them as certain et cetera et
cetera they don't enter new
relationships with the best intentions
right so you don't have to work on
yourself because everything's been given
to you yeah especially if you're an
attractive woman so i feel like all
those words just put out there yeah
describes a lot of women in today's
system but i feel like i don't know if
you recall the question was does
everyone deserve love you said no yeah
and then you describe those words that's
um that's why i said that sounds like a
woman to me i just want to get your face
um okay well um so would you say bitter
baby mamas don't deserve love um
some don't let's be let's be real like
some don't because um
if you're going if you're going to be
really honest with yourself
um which a lot of people aren't um they
if we're talking specifically about baby
moms like a lot of baby moms or baby
fathers um use the child as a um form
yeah as a as a porn in order in order to
get certain things from the ex-partner
in order to make a point and stuff like
that so like i do understand what you're
saying but i just feel as though like if
we're looking at it a lot deeper let's
just examine humanity rather than
examine oh yeah it's just the baby mom
because that's not always the scenario
in which we look at society so did
did the man make her crazy
or was she already like that because
you're the one who decided to have a
child with you so
why is it why do we owe it whenever we
put accountability on women we always
flip it and then blame the man
because it's just like oh so i said i
said bitter baby mamas so i didn't say
all baby mamas i i i
said bitter baby mama yeah and then you
and then your first reaction is well
what about the man yeah
of the man you know men talk they say a
lot of stuff they feed you lies and you
know they make you feel a certain way so
therefore you might have to start acting
yeah but you don't have to act you don't
have to act psycho like that's a choice
like you chose to act psycho yeah but
it's mental health isn't it
the guy drove it to that point no no i
mean here's the thing i've been in a
toxic relationship before i don't do i
never did the crazy [ __ ] i see a lot of
these girls do on social media that's a
choice everyone reacts differently
i know but that's that's a choice that's
who you are that shows a lack of
character if that's how you react but
you don't like you know how much you
know you're not you're not a child like
you're you're a grown adult it makes
decisions it doesn't define who you are
just like when you have arguments in a
relationship or even with your siblings
absolutely there might be times where
you actually physically fight okay it
absolutely defines who you are the
actions that you choose when you are
angry absolutely define who you are if
if a man on the street got angry and
murdered somebody they wouldn't say oh
you didn't murder him it's okay you were
saying it happened so many you're in
that situation
not necessarily but not to the judge the
world doesn't owe you understanding and
and the thing is in life what pearl's
saying is like in life yet the only
thing you can control like literally the
only thing you can control is yourself
you you cannot control anyone else their
actions what they do but you can control
your own actions no matter what so
whatever you do you have to take account
accountability for whatever you've done
if you get robbed on the street or you
get thing you've walked down a bad
street or you weren't looking out for
things you still have to take
accountability of your actions no one's
saying that the person who robbed you
isn't a bad person no one's saying the
men that didn't treat you right isn't a
bad person but at the end of the day you
still have to take accountability for
your own actions because that's the only
thing you can control
without saying no one's saying you
should take accountability
mental abuse is real so you don't know
what that could do to the brain yeah
like but you should be accountable then
leave
if you choose if you make a choice as an
adult to stay and then you act a certain
way because you chose to say that's your
own fault
and it says let me fit it let me finish
and it says something about your
character it says something about your
character because if if it's in you to
act crazy then you're crazy
i i agree with you everybody's got a
little crazy on them
i agree with you but then like i just
believe that like we can't hold everyone
to a particular standard when like you
were saying about like people having
mental health issues or like if somebody
has driven the person crazy like we all
know that women are more so emotionally
inclined so sometimes
yeah
again i said unstable
stable unstable whatever you define it
as but i just feel as though like
sometimes we don't necessarily consider
like a man's influence on a woman and
going back to like one of your um
questions earlier about how is it that
when like a question like oh the baby
mum is brought up why do women always
flip it back on on the man and i feel as
though partially that's a defense
mechanism because us as women we're all
we always get the um
negative
um aspect of like what what life could
be or like some of our decisions and not
necessarily see what do you mean what do
you mean by the negative aspect um so
say for example um two people got
together they had sex they had a baby
um so we're speaking about the baby mom
however like the baby mom has been um
making specific choices to restrict the
man from seeing the child or whatever um
sometimes we don't necessarily see that
there are reasons behind it some men are
just wackless some men are um yeah but
so so are some women no no i understand
that
let me kind of
who's the gatekeeper of six padding
who's the gatekeeper of sex the woman
however men are men
but men can be manipulative men can sell
you a dream like
i i understand where you guys are coming
from but it's just like like like i'm
saying like a man is more militant in in
terms of their expression
a man a man does things to obtain um sex
women do things to obtain love so the
reason why a woman would have sex with a
man is because she feels as though she
will receive love from a man the reason
why a man says to a woman i love you is
because he feels that if he says i love
you he will receive sex from her then
he's the four in that situation both of
them not really because he gets what he
wants well so you don't get what you
want but you know what
that's the manipulation that's the right
that
is that manipulation that's a good
salesman
that's a good salesman
i think think about what my guy who was
sitting there earlier said when he said
um before when men used to get involved
with women you needed another man's
approval in order to get that woman now
women are screaming this i'm independent
i can do all of my own and you're making
hella bad decisions then you say well
don't tell me i'm making bad decisions
like i just do what the [ __ ] i want to
do regardless of the repercussions as in
society yeah for me that's ludicrous
that makes no sense but also what you've
got to remember is that we live in like
i think you were saying earlier
not only that but like we live in a
hyper sexual society like everywhere you
look at women because of women i don't
know women we sexualize ourselves look
at i was just at carnival this weekend
the amount of half naked women i saw
that we sexualize ourselves it's not
just that if the guy looks at you
naked you're going to be like what the
[ __ ] you're looking at but your cheeks
are just in my face
yeah not that i agree with that 100
percent
so what so if i told you as my girl here
that you can't wear certain clothes
you're going to feel away controlling
yeah 100
controllers
on this for me yeah girls want to reveal
most of the clothes because they want
more attention out there so if you're
saying it's controlling because you're
still looking for more attention from
different men yeah you guys take it like
that yeah no but you've noticed i want
to just have one address it's not for 10
no it's not i generally want to dress
because i want to jump because you're
walking you're walking around with a for
sale sign when you have a man that's
disrespectful
and yeah yeah what you want to wear just
because he doesn't like what i'm wearing
i'm so what no
one at a time one at a time
okay do you believe in submitting to a
man whose authority you trust
to a certain extent submission to me is
very iffy okay would you trust a guy's
judgment it depends
the way you're answering is no so you're
not a submissive woman depends on the
situation because no no
the answer you're giving is no because
because the only the only right answer
if i said a guy whose judgment you could
trust i didn't say just anyone i said
whose judgment you can trust and you
said it depends and that that's
indicating that you can't trust that
judgment even even back in the day if
when they needed to receive the approval
uh dads were proven guys who beat the
women or cheat
there are exceptions but it wasn't the
rule is that your view on men
is that your view on men all the men
throughout history were just beating
their women no i never said that no i
know but that's what you're implying
when you say anything when you say when
you say when we're talking when we're
when we're talking about a general rule
and you're saying oh but they approve
things like beating their mothers you're
saying that like it's common and the
words we use are important i feel like
it was acceptable to a certain extent
and it was hidden
so there was a lot so so that is your
view on man no it's not right on men
it's just what happened is okay but
reality okay but that's your view on
matt what data do you have to support
that no no no i'm saying what what data
do you have to support that that was
relevant that that happened all the time
what data i never said all the time i
said there were men out there proven
guys that had this background okay would
you say it was happening by and large
would you say
talking as if that was a common thing no
the way you're trying to generalize it
and i'm just saying that it still
happened and i thought but exceptions
don't make the rule
there's no such thing as rules rules are
meant to be broken what do you mean
there's no you don't think there's ever
there you don't think there's any
generalities in society like some things
are just but does that mean they're
supposed to be followed no
no but then then people wouldn't get
together if if if everyone was the
exception it's not the exception then
people just wouldn't get together like
then you can't say anything
if we can't agree that there are general
things in society we can't have a
conversation about is that the base of
life just to procreate and get with
people then no but no we but we're just
saying enlarge kind of yeah yeah i mean
it's saying when when people when the
girls were saying like oh i dress for me
i dress for i dress for myself i think
that makes no sense right because
if you were the only person on the
planet like the only person you wouldn't
bother putting on makeup or anything
like that
you it literally makes zero sense it's
just let a girl go out for a week yeah
or let's say a month and get no
attention
but she'll end up butt naked on the
street saying someone looks
i feel as though sometimes like our our
perception of like men and women
are um
different or that like you
people haven't met a woman that's like
um feels naturally confident in like her
natural beauty or um doesn't seek male's
attention and i feel as though
even though it may be like the exception
like people don't necessarily come into
contact with that type of woman hence
why like the example is cap or it's like
because because because there's no women
then she wouldn't wear makeup if you
were in your natural beauty no one would
wear makeup like my wife doesn't wear
makeup but my point is like yours even
if it's not for guys attention it might
be because you want to look pretty for
other girls but then why are you trying
to why are you trying to one-up yourself
over other girls why are you trying to
beautify yourself
compared to the rest of the world and
men do it as well but men just do it in
different ways right so we we are um
always trying to get a better job or
better normal success that's the
illusion we speak about so it's like a
man will happily say that i do x y and z
for a woman but then for a woman to say
in the reverse he's like no i'd do it
for me i did for this idea for that in
reality
no thought that you have is original so
everything we see is regurgitated
information so it's actually impossible
to not be influenced by the people
around you yeah a woman starts to say i
do it for me when it's virtually
impossible it makes zero sense
it doesn't mean that there isn't things
that women do for men there are things
just like say that then don't be like do
it for me
it also doesn't mean that a girl doesn't
dress up or put on makeup for self-love
for herself yeah exactly self-love
self-care
you're telling me the girls at carnival
walking around a thong are just doing it
for themselves but wait i don't speak
for those girls
the masquerade people because that's
different that's
so wait why is it acceptable in brazil
for girls to be wearing the thongs and
this everyone is church and everything
culture
i mean yeah and that's the culture that
they find attractive we're not we're not
in brazil why are we talking about
brazil
it's like we go out of our way to find
like the craziest craziest exceptions
why
i just feel like because they exist yeah
i know but we're not saying they don't
exist but
okay let me finish okay i think as grown
adults we can agree that there are
exceptions to every rule but we can make
statements based on general tendencies
in society without having to stay with
every statement there's an exception i
think we can just know i i also think
it's a dream it's like it's like me
saying like uh i can run 100 meters in
nine seconds it's like and it's like
i can't but you're like oh but usain
bolt run it in nine seconds so why can't
i run it in nine seconds or if i say men
men are generally taller than women and
then you point to the one guy that isn't
there's a lot of exceptions in the world
like there's seven billion people
i know do you want to talk about every
single one of them or dude we should
maybe would you say maybe that's not
productive to a conversation no i feel
like maybe they'll make people realize
the extent of how we don't appreciate
certain things the minimal things you
don't you don't what are you okay what
do you mean by that by the minimal
things
the small like the exceptions okay such
things as the exception okay what do you
mean by appreciating the exceptions
like because like this just sounds like
nothing like we don't bring no awareness
we don't talk about it enough so like
what what exceptions what do we not talk
about just like now we're talking about
women dressing up so we need to we need
there's women that do there's women that
don't uh-huh and we need to bring up
brazil why because it happens it's
acceptable in that in that place
why is it not and why is it not
acceptable honestly
it's sort of acceptable everywhere if
you go to the beaches now not just that
brazilian women
are very very submissive women so like
when it comes to how they treat their
man you can't even come close to how the
western women treat their men so that's
not even a comparison so you can let
them dress and shake bum bum because
when they come home they show ultimate
respect whereas a lot of western guys
are coming home and trying to beef their
man
i find it weird how you guys also
straight away you all said like that's
controlling right and and it is just
like a respect thing like it's not even
like i'm just asking you like why if you
truly love this person and this person
doesn't like that you dress that way
then you should at least for our respect
for the person that you love that is the
love of your life at least
willing to do that you know like like
and same the other way around if my wife
told me to do something
because i love and care for her i would
do do that as well like if it really
annoyed her would you guys be cool with
your your man going to the strip club
with his boys yeah yeah yeah i don't
mind yeah i'll go with him no no i'm
saying bye
bye by himself you wouldn't care no
no i don't care
i think it's because strip club is like
like most guys don't do anything at a
strip club so i think you have to push
it like
a little further
you just
[Music]
trust me here you girls will say you
don't you you don't care but you'll be
blowing up his phone you'll be calling
all your girls you're planning on
revenge and doing all kind of madness so
let's keep our back club
forward do you think this [ __ ] club
if if a guy comes late yo you're already
assuming that he's cheated on you no no
baby
yeah that is the majority of females
that are insecure then yeah because a
lot of um relationships are not built on
trust on our respect
don't you think it's disrespectful to
wear something revealing when you have a
boyfriend uh yeah and no and the reason
why i say yeah can i get yes or no
no no no yes yes or no okay i i i bow
out of my mind
did you say do you think he's respectful
yeah do you think it's respectful when
you have when you have a man to be
wearing something very revealing that he
wouldn't approve of well i don't know i
don't know about his approval or not i
would say that if it was my husband then
i would consider it but if if you're my
boyfriend then i'll decide that i want
to wait hold on you just say consider
yeah that means that but the thing is
i'm not gonna go out like with my ass
hanging out but um if you're saying that
i just i'm not gonna do nothing too mad
so you're saying that if it was your
boyfriend that you wouldn't so he should
wife you to get comp someone feel like
75 percentage of submissiveness so
somehow gets more so
you're showing him you're showing him
what he doesn't want and then you expect
to get better outcomes by showing him
i'm not going to listen to you now but
put a ring on it
see this is this is we're doing it again
we're doing it again where we say we say
something about women and then we push
it on the mat take it down to billy ball
i can't take account
one thing
you're always thinking from your
specific lens yeah the reason a man is
telling you not to behave and dress that
way it's because he knows what other men
you behave like him are gonna do yeah
but then let's say for example because
i've been in a situation where i've been
with a girl she's dressed mad and then
we've got into an altercation because
another boy has grabbed her cheek that
could have been avoidable has she
dressed differently but now i have to
punch up her next man because of
stupidness you did when i could have
just told you babes that's a bit too
much but they're not sure you're telling
because if he says don't wear that then
you wear it and there's a problem
because of it you wouldn't say that's on
you when he when he told me that's
that's on the man that wasn't raised
right yeah
that parent
but it's like it's like there's a
there's a
there's a difference between going into
a situ it's like okay if a dude get mo
it gets mugged at night because he's
walking alone with a big chain around
his neck do you really feel bad for him
see i i always feel like po you have to
go to extreme with them so you have to
say he's waving it around
and then you're like no you don't feel
me
when i'm on a dark bird i have to put my
jewels in my pocket
do you think it's smart to just leave
them out
no okay okay i have expensive camera
equipment okay is it smart for me to go
down to the bad part of london grab my
my nicest camera here and just wave it
around for people and people to take
they probably wouldn't know the value
okay okay can you answer the question
would that be smart would that be smart
well
probably not no
okay so could you could you see from the
men's point of view it's probably not
smart to walk around half naked when you
have a man but does that give them a man
the right to touch you no it doesn't
give them the right to touch you but
it's about taking yourself out of bad
situations if you can and like women
walk around the world like like we're so
spoiled we're so spoiled as women
because we're so used to being protected
like men protect us every day in the
world they built the infrastructure for
us
when someone is attacking you who do you
call
your man
well or the police but even if you call
the police you want a man not a female
yeah
no no you're right you're right though
if you've got like five muggers on you
and two females come up you'd be like
what the like what the hell happened
right
what was the question i'm saying okay
men protect us every day because when
you are mugged who would you call if
someone breaks into your apartment
or my uncles yeah yeah the men yeah
that's what i'm saying men tamed the
world for it used to be wars all the
time if we go into war who's going
the men
met men built the world they protect us
and now we're spoiled to the point we
want to go out of our way to put
ourselves in dangerous situations and
and you have to be like and then we feel
entitled to security sorry sorry no i
was gonna say if you want a good guy as
well then you need to be good as well
like if a girl if you generally want a
guy that cares for you and then you say
no i'm gonna dress in this way
like you're just not gonna get those
guys that you're looking for then i feel
like that goes back to what pearl was
saying about like um
being submit
submissive to a guy that you genuinely
like respect
i feel like that comes into play a lot
maybe
being submissive to a guy that you
generally respect could you talk more
about that so so say for example like if
if you um respect like your partner or
you value what he has to um say or like
say for example we say that men are
leaders and then they are meant to lead
us to green a posture for example like a
woman would kind of look to her partner
for direction in some sort of capacity
so if me um saying that i value my
partner's decisions and his
decision-making and i and i trust that
his decision-making will be in like will
be fitting for us both then
i would consider like
not necessarily changing myself but like
some of the decisions that i would make
because it may have a negative impact on
us both and not just affecting him but
when you use the words i would consider
yeah like i don't really it makes me not
really believe you
because it like a real submissive woman
would say i would listen to my man
on that note would you go see your
conditioning feminine because that's
what it sounds like you're feminine
based on conditions that your man does
certain things
and to give a flip example is like me
saying i'm going to wear a dress and
paint my nails until i meet a girl that
makes me masculine it sounds stupid but
then
that's kind of what these lot are saying
it's like ah i will do this that and
other for my man if he does extra i feel
as though it's because of um primary and
secondary socialization like when we're
taught by like our family as well as
society what we need to do in order to
maintain or like have a long lasting
thriving relationship those are the kind
of things that um we look at and
especially like within media and stuff
like we see that like women don't
respect men in media so it's like oh on
a subconscious level that's what we take
in and then we may um regurgitate those
sort of actions without even knowing
that doesn't make you okay though i'm
not saying that it does but i'm just
saying that that's for part and parcel
of life
yeah because we look at our parents
relationship and then we say we don't
want that then you look at social media
and you see that doesn't work either but
then that's what you choose to emulate
but then you want a successful
relationship yeah you've seen a good
example but you ignore it and then chase
the bad one and what i don't understand
how that makes sense um i feel as though
like we chase bad things because it's
it's thrilling it's exciting like it it
kind of um
it's like an elixir that sounds white no
no no no no no
no the reason the reason why i'm saying
that is because like it when even going
back to oh sorry even going back to the
point that you made about like baby
mamas like a lot of those examples are
extremely toxic and like a lot of
relationships are very toxic and because
we because we maybe despise our parents
because they had such an amazing
relationship and we can't find that it's
like oh settling for something that's
just like
you by and large admitted women love
drama
that proves the point that women are
attracted to the pookies and rabies yeah
they're bad boys because they can't help
even though you say oh we don't like
toxic men but you talk about them 24 7.
you open your legs 24 7 like an
automatic door
that's that's the that's the real life
let's keep her back
if women if women if women didn't like
getting cheated on why do they always
pick the guys that can cheat
not because they're cheating themselves
well that doesn't make sense go on
um
they're cheating themselves what do you
mean by like as in
okay so some people they only um get
into a relationship because it's like
like back to the conversation that we
were having earlier they're settling but
they're settling because it's just like
oh okay
i've met the standards of society but
i'm still going to do what i want to do
or what
my heart's desire so they will be
looking at other men speaking to other
men like socializing with other men just
to get that um that acceptance or
acknowledgement from other people
that still doesn't make sense now you
see what is it what she's trying to say
is you would settle for the nice guy
because let's say you know what you
couldn't get the bad boy because let's
say let's say obviously a girl's prime
time is from 18 to 25 and let's say
you're 29 or 30. obviously the good guys
are not going to be accessible to you
anymore because they're all wifed up so
obviously you're going to wife even that
nice guy and you're going to obviously
cheating him cheat on him because he
doesn't really give you that excitement
he doesn't really you don't really like
him but you're selling him because you
said yes
[Laughter]
um i'm gonna take a second i'm gonna
read super chats um
okay guys thank you so much for all of
the super chats that you have guys have
been given you guys are blowing it up
this show um we've gotten a ton all of
the super chats are going towards new
equipment for the studio um that
includes new camera equipment um also
different types of um
we're gonna start signing talent soon
and we're gonna start new channels one
of those is gonna be anti's channel but
we need money to start it up so a lot of
the super chats are going towards talent
that we're going to be signing soon okay
joshua cintron modern making modern
women take accountability um it's easier
just walking into the sun
pajero majestic relationships are 10
physical attraction 90 psychology let's
go pearl get me through these on through
these through zoom um clifford range
they will say anything to avoid
accountability for their decisions and
their actions silly sausage ish must be
making more bread he splashed out for a
second nike tick
no comment ish nothing yeah some super
so
send super chat so we can give ish a
raise
yo
let's go people beans um b and sneko has
entered the chat uh mr missing four four
if he was my husband i will consider it
dot dot jesus billy boy i can't comment
members only i am that's weird i don't
know why i would do that um chris the
girls bring up exceptions because
they're trying to win an argument while
everyone else is just trying to get to
the truth they tackle at their own jokes
and make no sense like useless children
are modern struggles the same old modern
women they're not aware and they don't
want to be i cover many of these topics
myself chris girl in the yellow only
submits to the authority of krispy kreme
modern struggles thank you for the super
chat emone
ammonius um this might sound bad but
he's right my boy calls them six month
girlfriends the guy is out of her league
and he's just smashing for free zodiac
256b
they feed you lies try telling women the
truth and watch their fur fly we
literally cannot tell you the truth
because of your feelings being king
um will it wissium thibaut thank you for
the super chat silly sausage if a girl
has an issue over restricting instagram
for a partner out of respect you're a
304 simple you're more worried about
you're losing your potential
i'm not going to say that word um list
over uh building a future you're not
trustworthy beans what about say adhd in
a relationship adam sutton women only
count boyfriends and full
monty for body count i dated a girl
whose count was two but later later blew
18 once at a party oh jesus
um beans fix the discord link please um
i'll let our team know alexander way
boss hogg i can't believe you scammed me
yasmine mgtow by logic stop marrying it
staying with men you don't even like
you're lying and stealing money and
ruining your life
life men's lives your kids lives in
society two stop lying um
pedjero majestic pearl not pal voice to
the chat beans we need more australians
on the panel sick and tired of all these
british accents speaking
nonsense um benevolent
patrice i'm here for
pearl's long pins
pajero majestic hey pal i love your
channel i am a relationship counselor
and a coach i'd love to zoom as i'm in
australia the biggest flex is a woman
that can do everything herself but
allows a man to do it without her ego
getting in the way
project utopian women get off by
temporarily rejecting men they go get
off forever by gloating over earnings
it's a trap hero that one girl said guys
don't want virgins i've never heard of a
guy saying man i would have dated her
but she's a virgin
okay
so
i have a question for the panel
what is your ideal partner
and what do you offer your ideal partner
are we good
why don't you start start with me okay
um i look for someone
i look for someone with the same values
as me
i previously mentioned
i would want someone with a strong work
ethic for sure that's
very important to me
and someone intelligent so that when we
marry i feel comfortable submitting
because i trust the judgment
and what do you offer your ideal partner
i know how to cook i know to clean
i love children
i love to garden as well
so
i could make basically we wouldn't have
to worry on a grocery store because like
i'm my own grocery store
um
i would say i'm a good friend my friends
say that i listen very well and
i'm very supportive of the people i care
about
okay what about you so i look for
someone that's um hard-working ambitious
a go-getter someone that's a family man
um
someone that's
you know loving
takes care of me is very supportive
and what i often return is i'm very
supportive
um
i get my own money
um
i could be a good i'll be a good wife
and you know take care of the kids cook
clean you know i can do it oh i'm good
in the bedroom you know i got the full
package
okay go ahead um for me
um i love a family man i'm someone
that's very caring supportive
um someone that takes his time to
understand me
um and also like i can have like very
good conversations with and is also
ambitious for me
um
[Music]
i am i know that i'm very opinionated um
so like that can come with a bit of you
know arguments whatever here and there
but like i'm a very like family
orientated person like i love children i
have younger siblings which like
um taking care of them as well as like
um being very driven and motivated but
also you know wanting wanting to have a
family
okay what do you think
well first and foremost i look for
honesty
which is not easy
um
i'm
i mean obviously you know my stage of
life things are slightly different but
um
you know in general i'm looking for
somebody to uh to grow old with
um which is quite you know i think
everybody should be looking for that um
um
yeah so honestly honesty
intelligence integrity
and um
yeah that's about it really and what do
you offer your ideal partner what do i
offer uh stability protection
um
i think those are you know two of the
most important things and
yeah and
you know i'll try to understand them
uh as much as they'll allow me but i
think that's you know that's a
that's what we tend to do we do try to
understand them and as much as they
allow us to okay
um i want a best friend someone that
knows how to listen and understand me
communicate a good communicator
um
someone that respects their family and
respects others as well
[Music]
yeah just someone that's confident and
that's funny as well
and what i offer i'm very motivating i'm
a good listener
i can do all the housework that's not a
problem um
yeah just someone that's going to be
like your ride or die
um
personally for me a submissive woman
that's going to get on my program
obviously
respectful
and uh
yeah it just has moles and some values
that we can actually correlate now what
i'm going to offer is my she's going to
enter into my world so she's going to
enter into my lifestyle
she's going to have emotional stability
oh yeah i'm she's going to be she's
going to feel secure
exactly she's going to feel secure and
safe what lifestyle does she get
if i become if i make it she's going to
have fun she's coming where she's coming
with me she's entering what does she get
like does she get any bags she wants i
need no no no she has to work
what about like vacations of course okay
okay but no bags
listen it depends
if she's a submissive woman that's
getting on my program then i will get
you it occasionally you tell me yo does
she get like a woman's version of
loyalty as well what do you mean so
you by her that's it no cheating no
nothing
now
if let's say that person becomes the one
percent
she's just gonna have to deal with a guy
that's gonna have options it's just what
it is bro because if you let's
you're not going to come across this guy
ever in your [ __ ] life bro so
either you go get in her program getting
his program or you go because there's
going to be other options that's going
to replace take your position
yeah but does that not mean you're
dating down
not really
because if you're in the one percent of
men and you're extremely desirable
and then you have a one percent like if
you're if you're in a one percent
and she doesn't have options then she
would be you would be dating down then
by the way no a woman
what do you mean by options because if
you're dating a one percent woman let's
just say you're a one percent man
and you're dating a one percent woman
she would have options as well
personally for me i wouldn't date a one
percent woman i'll date a regular woman
i'm talking from what men look for in
women
of one percent woman
a lot of guys what is it that guys look
for what what is it
like purity youth submission submissive
like if she was top one percent in all
those categories would you still be not
too young you know
i mean nothing crazy it gets sticky
because she has her own in it so even if
you cheat she can she or leave it don't
mild because
she has like the same level but
personally for me i would never get an a
will forgive us on the same level as me
all right so i understand the question
i would not cheat on her if she was
everything like if if this was like the
one percent girl so
loyalty uh submission
everything i could think of and she's a
one percenter then i'm thinking
i wouldn't risk losing
that woman that would be my mindset
don't get me wrong i don't know what
how life would turn out for me i don't
know if i accidentally
slip and fall
but yeah i wouldn't i wouldn't risk it
typically in relationships partners only
satisfy or meet the criteria of eighty
percent of what the person wants
so a lot of the times people cheat
thinking
oh like this person has twent has the
twenty percent that i'm looking for that
i wish she had and they leave the 80
percent for that 20
so
also i have a question so do you guys
think that cheating is morally okay
now
[Laughter]
if i'm not in a committed relationship
options is widely available for sure
yeah but if i'm i mean if i'm in a
relationship with a girl i'm not going
to cheat on you if i'm going to cheat on
you i'm going to let you know first
again
like if you're on some if you're on some
[ __ ] like let's say you're holding
sex for me i'm gonna tell you okay if
you're not gonna give me what i want i'm
gonna go for to other girls that's gonna
give me exactly what i want but would
you stay in the relationship
i mean it depends on the in a period of
time
for men and for women so like a man
cheating is like him buying another girl
house
where a woman cheating it's her it's her
sleeping with someone else
yes so i i understand that men are
biologically different
men i mean they're wired to kind of sow
their seed i understand that it's not in
their nature to be monogamous but that
doesn't mean it's beneficial for them
and their family and society as a whole
no i agree with you i don't i don't
condone cheating but i just think it's
like if you find a one percent guy
like it's like okay i don't feel bad for
nba wives that get cheated on what do
you think
yeah like you know what i mean so i
think the point is like if a guy has
like all of the things that women want
it's not likely that he's going to be
faithful and a lot like and i think
because i kind of come from a christian
like background too and i don't condone
it but it's like that's kind of how like
those groups run i know that they just
have they just like women shouldn't like
if loyalty truly matters to you you
shouldn't
like date something like you shouldn't
date or marry somebody that's going to
cheat on you if that matters to you
but i don't think that saying oh i have
options i i should be allowed to
exercise my options
is is necessarily healthy
see what i say this look men need to
maintain discipline in order to
safeguard against relationships modern
day relationships
however there's a fundamental difference
depending on at what stage you meet
about in his life
if you allow that man to grow if you see
the ambition
work with him help him develop as a man
and he attains that one percent status
by all means he should give you sexual
exclusivity but if you buy into his
lifestyle you meet him when it's already
made
then you don't deserve that then the
reason being is because
men have to create their value whilst
women are born of value so sex means
something completely different to us so
i think whilst i say many to maintain
discipline it's their choice because
a man
even to have a seat at the sexual
marketplace has to become something so
if you didn't help him become that thing
you can't demand that he be sexually
exclusive to you
well okay so i get i get what you said
but i think
so
yeah so if you if you work your way up
to the one percent
i do feel as though
like yes you may have options and you
can kind of sow your seed but if a woman
is in the one percent as well and you're
dating her but like from what male
standards right not necessarily
financially but physically emotionally
maturity intellectually
would you have a problem would you would
you have a problem with a woman
having a sugar daddy if the sugar daddy
had a vasectomy and you're not worried
about paternity tests
because because that would mean that
she's not like she's not content with
you providing and if you're married to a
woman and she's
still having sex with you but you're not
satisfied with that
are we doing this on the condition that
i'm also one percent individual yes then
then of course not why would i waste my
time over i could literally have almost
any woman that i want so why would you
yeah but but it's it's not easy to
replace a one percent woman just like
it's not easy to replace it it kind of
is though for those guys it's not that
hard the new girl turns 22 every day
we're like we're like women like when
are you ever going to be in contact with
the one percent guy again yeah but
occasionally
but realistically though like yeah
they're young
fertile beautiful
and some virginal women but
like do you want like a lot of drama
that comes out i'll say this ideally in
the scenario that you create and you
said if you do find a one percent woman
then
if respectful when she meets you then
she's a one percenter you should do what
you can to keep her the perspective i
come from is more the realistic aspect
where i can't determine whether you're
that one percent if i was to lose all my
earnings tomorrow would you be there for
me or are you just here for the good
times because i can't determine that
because you haven't been there from the
start you don't deserve my exclusivity
because if my money goes do you go
i would never know so that's exactly
what i was going to get to i think a lot
of people that talk about this on the
internet talking about like oh if i'm a
one percent person i should be allowed
to cheat like a lot of these guys don't
realize because like we've we've been
living in a bull market from 2009 to
present like people don't realize like
money can go very quickly
and so if i'm dating a guy that happens
to be in the one percent and he's
cheating on me while he's making all
this money if he loses it tomorrow
when he was in his prime when he had
options he was cheating on me so what
incentive do i have as a woman to to
really stick around well
i'm saying if i'm not married like and
it's just dating because i i v value
marriage a lot but what incentive do i
have to build this man up only for him
to
to sleep around and have sex with other
women and and treat other women
when i was the one that was building
that
that's what i said so if you help me
build with it then you'd absolutely you
deserve my sexual exclusivity but if
you've met me in my prime with all my
money you've just bought into my
lifestyle you just don't get that but if
you but if you didn't have money
realistically you're not gonna get like
the like hottest
girl like what what you would
i'm not saying i'm not seeing you i'm
talking i'm referring to a one percent
man like let's just say you met in high
school and you fell in love like that
guy on the video
like
oh gosh i don't want to insult him i
mean more like
um
you're probably not going to attract
like a victoria's secret model so like
if you were to attain the one percent
wouldn't you kind of look at her being
like um
i don't know i could probably find a
girl that's like better kind of thing i
just say look average men
they they aren't afforded the luxury of
cheating so they should absolutely be
faithful i'm going to say once you've
once you've achieved a certain status
then the world is your oyster and that
includes women
so
again if you've built with me then you
have every reason that man i should stay
loyal to because you're a part of the
reason he was successful if he had
nothing to do with him attaining his
success then you can't demand
stuff off him like why why you when is
it
like literally i could open my eyes as
women everywhere it doesn't make any
sense logically especially if i want to
fulfill my biological imperative because
what you're asking to do is conform to
your standard which puts me at a
disadvantage yeah but there's there's a
lot of things that i want to do that are
not healthy for me and that would have a
negative effect on society like um well
i'm not i'm not into drugs or anything
but like for me i love sugar so if i
like consumed sugar constantly and i was
spending all my money at bakeries and i
was and i had and then i ended up
getting a diabetic problem and i ended
up getting heavy like that would that
would be a problem for my health that
would be like a burden on society in
many ways like that doesn't mean just
because you want to do it doesn't mean
it's good well society was society was
built on polygamy actually like every
all every king throughout all of history
has had multiple women so to say it's
not healthy for society when that's how
society was built is just incorrect but
if you love this woman if you genuinely
love her why would you want to put her
through such insecurities such agony why
would you want your sons to look up to
because men men love men love in
different ways yes i understand
forgetting the key thing
what i'm really saying is
find your man young
and stay with him that's really what i'm
saying but your women are out here
sitting on the sidelines waiting for a
guy to blow up and then say look oh hey
here i am you haven't done nothing to
deserve that so why do you deserve that
lifestyle when i've had to work day and
night killing myself most successful men
are like you don't understand what they
have to go through to attain that level
of status but then to say well i've just
come out of nowhere and now you have to
give me all that you have
plus give me your exclusivity it makes
zero sense because you haven't had to do
that you haven't had to struggle to
reach that status if you had done it
with him you deserve everything he has
to offer and more but if he didn't do
that with him there's no reason why he
deserved that yeah and i and i
understand but men and women are
different women are kind of born like a
ten or they're born in eight they're
born of four men do have to build
themselves
and that's just the common understanding
that that you have is and then if you're
a ten and you're submissive and you have
some sort of skill and you're loyal and
you're nice and you're not argumentative
like
like men like
historically speaking have worked have
built like have put everything into
their business into their career so that
they could attain a woman like that so
then to say that she's not entitled to
anything i mean no one's entitled to
anything but i think i think the point
is they're never gonna have the same
amount of leverage as a one percent guy
because a new girl turns i mean 22
throughout history 18 whatever it is
every day so you're just you're never
gonna have the same amount of leverage
as a one percent guy i'm not saying it's
right i'm not i'm not putting on my
moral judgment like my dad's a top one
percent guy he didn't cheat on my mom
but like the point is those guys have
the leverage and if they want to do it
they can and a lot of girls are okay
with it yeah they can do it but i think
you should
certainly be clear about it before you
enter a car
most even in the red pill most coaches
will say be honest
yeah i mean it might it may be difficult
to find a woman that would be willing to
do you think
a lot of women a lot of women can i have
i have another thing too because i know
a lot of like guys they're very much in
fear of marriage which i understand
because the divorce courts are very much
in their favor
but like how could you honestly say like
that
they they can cheat
and then
like if i'm married to a guy and he
cheats i if i have kids i i don't know
if i would leave for sure but if he
cheated and got some girl pregnant
like that's grounds for divorce for me
and like if you cheat and you're you're
you're a one percent guy
like she can take you for all of your
money so like
i just feel like it's kind of leading
men astray in some ways
no i i agree with you i think it's a
high risk i don't i don't morally agree
with it but i'm not trying to change
like what the what is the world yeah and
like when you're in certain circles
that's just how it is like wives will
shake side chicks hands
yeah they'll just become sister wives
i also feel like there are sacrifices
that are made on both parties typically
when a man when a man enters a committed
relationship he promises that he won't
have sex with other women and a woman
promises that she won't leave him when a
man with better resources or
is better looking or whatever it is
comes along right but he's talking about
the girls that wait at the finish line
so he's talking about the girls that
just want a guy that has everything like
it's like you're selling a disney fairy
tale when you want a guy that has all of
the things you look for and he's going
to give you monogamy like it is a top
one percent earner i think that's dicey
though because like from my perspective
i'm 20 but i know exactly what i want i
want to live in the mountains i want to
have a strong loving masculine man that
shares my values i've already said this
where i can live in the mountains
homeschool my kids and we just kind of
escape from modern society
but like i i happen to date guys that
are
typically like late 20s early 30s
because they know what they want they
have their life together i'm not here
like being someone's babysitter a lot of
the 25 year old guys that i know that i
happen to be friends with are still
gaming playing like you know they act
like children and i don't think it's
necessarily wrong for a woman to want
somebody that that has their life
together but do you demand a guy that
makes like 120 000 pounds a year
no i mean if he happens to have it
that's great but it's not like right
that's what i'm saying you're not you're
not coming in with unrealistic standards
you just want to homeschool your kids
and live in the mountains and i think
what eddie's talking about more is women
that wait at the finish line and are
after superficial things well if they're
after superficial things you know not to
wife her uh maybe so look at jeff bezos
because oh wait yeah okay sorry i
thought you were talking about mckenzie
it's the i don't know where mckenzie is
mackenzie's the one that was with him
when he started the business no no i'm
talking about the new one okay like the
the one that was like hitting on leo in
front of him oh my goodness
yeah but i mean if you're a one percent
guy you should know if you if you know
like anything about divorce courts that
like maybe try not to go for girls like
that but it's hard these days i think
it's hard i think it's hard for men
especially they're throwing yourself at
you
like like i said i always preach i may
need to maintain discipline and you
should properly sift through women
before you pick the one
but
when the woman comes with an agenda
they're powerful attaining their goal
so because the
women will target footballers and they
find a way to do it i don't know how but
they find a way to do it and it happens
so i got like i can't speak for it but
if a woman wants a guy she's attractive
enough she'll find a way to get into a
circle
yes that's true
but i still feel like
i i get what you're saying and i
understand it but i do think that it
should definitely be clear
if cheating is on the table i agree most
people will say that like a lot of and
um those circles a lot of people have
just like an arrangement
where they they kind of know what it is
yeah yes
that's not my thing like i wouldn't do
that but
i think it's interesting that we're
spending so much time talking about one
percent of the population
when
it doesn't really apply to most of us
i think there are a lot of people who
would like to be a member of the one
percent
um and you know good for them
but behave like it
when you are
part of the one percent
not just because you have ambitions to
be part of the one percent
and
sure as hell
don't change on your misses
it is disloyal
okay um i am going to read super chats
but we're going to close out the show so
if you have any final thoughts feel free
to like think now while i read the super
chats and then you will go around
um sagan um can ninja bae drop her ig
look at they're simping over you in the
comments they're symphony over you
i saw that coming there's so many people
that will message about relationships
afterwards
she's not putting her id out there
now i said all the comments they're
stemping over you oh i thought you said
ninja i was like no no it's like
they're they're talking about your oh
yeah
she was wearing it
is is the ninja woman single if so is
she looking to date she seems
intelligent disciplined high eq and
feminine she's definitely one percent
there are men who are disciplined and
would never cheat silly sausage to the
female version of phone jacker on the
couch you said it the woman's loyalty
test is to stay when a guy has nothing a
guy's loyalty test is to leave when he
said he he has everything you just said
you'd leave clifford range they just
admitted they are not submissive in
their argumentative so how will they get
their ideal partner chris um the disney
fantasy that women have of building a
one percent man office so delusional
most women don't build they move in and
a one percent man can replace a woman
faster than she can replace him mgtow by
logic for every negative interaction
there needs to be a minimum of five to
ten positive ones or the relationship
will die this includes overturns over
tunes for affection and sex um tim
neutron
this is why a female this is why the
female the only one with a is the only
one with a mask on she doesn't know the
cdc removed their health rule unmasked
meanings they don't work to be safe from
covenant can i interject yeah guys it's
because i don't want to get fired i work
i work at a very woke sort of industry
so that's the only reason why
eli i don't condone cheating polygamy is
a separate conversation alexander link
why is the chick with the mask there
she's not adding value to the
conversation she's just talking spacey
wtf semaine tagan the flower dress girl
is giving wifey um billy boy
billyboypearl what's a member because
i'm subscribed have all notifications
but can't comment you should be able to
um nsx congrats guys you're blowing up
and you deserve it billy boy pearl
something's up with the chat no access
um stephen tumming robe in honor of our
armed forces please blur out the army on
pink shirts before you post things on
youtube drazian gaming um yo army red
answer me what is the key that opens
many door what is a key that opens many
doors compared to a lock that opens many
keys
smegan tegan um the woman
the women these women make me never want
to what a wife bro zero respect joshua
cintron making modern women take
accountability it's just easier to walk
into the sun i'm gonna refresh it really
quick guys like the video while you're
at it subscribe to the channel ring the
notification but also go follow our
clips channel we have a new one it's
called pearl daily okay and we do it
with different editors so you guys can
just see different editing styles and
different clips channels so
um if you want to go subscribe to that
it has a lot of really cool shorts on it
um john yarbor um two facts a real man
doesn't want a roast beef sandwich with
meat hanging out no real man would let a
woman put him in the friend zone love
the new set my girl pearl smed
that was the ig one okay
so um do you want to give your final
thoughts um well it was lovely talking
to everyone
um i hope to
meet more people that think the same
because i think it was really inspiring
you know it's really easy to get kind of
put in a corner on the internet and
think no one agrees with you so if you
guys you know have similar views to mine
feel free to
follow me on locals uh linda
alves.locals.com feel free to message me
i'd love to talk to you guys
yeah you guys can see what i actually
look like on locals too so
[Laughter]
my final thoughts are a very interesting
conversation
um and yeah thanks for having
me on the podcast yeah thanks for coming
yeah um same for me i feel like this um
whole conversation was really refreshing
and allowed me to kind of challenge my
own
ways of thinking
and i loved like how there was so many
different opinions and stuff which was
really good so yeah thank you and it was
lovely being on your foot yeah thanks
for coming go ahead
um well first and foremost thank you
pearl for inviting me i know and i'm not
part of the target demographic to uh to
join join in
um
really enjoyed it i hope that my
perspective gave people a bit of you
know food for thought
and uh lastly these three ladies here
have their own podcast
if you want to if you want to see them
again then um
then what's the free survive podcast
yeah freeze a vibe
there you go um yeah very dynamic
conversation loved the different
characters personalities different views
thanks for having me
yeah wish i had more screen time but i
appreciate it
there'll be more mics next week too bad
you came on this one
sorry keep going any final thoughts um
[Music]
obviously for me i still think that one
percent guys like
they can have options like for me
if let's say the girl actually
built like built with him yeah if you
check this that statistics of loads of
celebrities like denzel washington
uh who else
but those kind of people they were with
the guy when he had nothing and that
bugs him alone that's all the guys even
though let's say when he becomes one
percent
in majority case majority of cases
females are gonna fall themselves at the
guy but the guy is still gonna stay
loyal to the girl because he loves the
girl and even if they do divorce he's
gonna still take care of her and the
kids because you know that she was there
for me when i had nothing so yeah
could i just yeah so could i just
interject sorry sir to interrupt but uh
could i just interject and point out
that boris johnson is one of the one
percent
yeah i mean i mean
just
just to go off what brandon said right
uh i i actually like income wise i am in
the top one percent right and exactly
what eddie said my wife was with me
before i got rich so i was in debt at 22
i was earning like 22k
and now
that we're together and she's still with
me i wouldn't cheat on her because
because she was with me from the
beginning she would so i know that she
was with me even when i was poor right
even when i was fat like i was fatter
than this you know and she was she used
to be a
car model as well so it was like she
decided to pick me and trust me and
everything and i even remember she was
like gave me money for like um a laptop
to start my writing and everything like
that so it's like
i wouldn't want to hurt her so what what
um linda said right i wouldn't do that
because
it's just shitty but
but the problem is if you were one
percent and you're meeting girls you
don't get to the trust bit or the the
thingy bit unless you lose all your
money so how can you pick the right girl
it's nearly impossible so that's why the
best relationships are the ones where
they're with you before
and then and then you get turned into
the one percent those are the code girls
that you can give soft treatment yeah
and try to so girls you should shouldn't
well not you girls specifically but what
the message is is don't aim for high
like right don't go for the guys that
already a hundred grand 200 grand or
whatever don't go for that go for a guy
that you do see potential in like people
used to do in the past you'd go for the
most caramel charismatic guy in the
village or whatever you know like don't
just be shallow on tinder and stuff like
that actually read their profile and see
what do they have ambitions and stuff
and then build up if you want a truly
good relationship that's my ending
um there's three more oh no oh no i
exited okay there's three more super
chats i'm going to read before the end
of the show okay now you said that i
apologize i do the same if you're
getting a bank from 10 new roth um
silly sausage to the chat youtube is
very woke you can't comment if when you
say anything negative about women they
censor it it's crazy um james sharp
funny how the masked lady is more
beautiful than the woman that showed
their faces it is called character and
integrity take notes
okay guys um thank you so much for
watching tonight there is um almost 3
000 live viewers at one point which is
great everyone clap hey
[Applause]
um okay um so as you already know if you
have watched two or more lives and you
don't subscribe we have beef so make
sure you subscribe to the channel guys
follow our two clips channels there's
pearl daily and just pearly clips follow
both of those um we have three
membership tiers so sign up for the five
dollar tier if you want to be a part of
the chap next time if you want to see a
behind-the-scenes look at the penthouse
which is pretty cool right yeah everyone
everyone's snotting yep um sign up
that's our 10 tier
on top of that go follow my instagram
just.pearlythings and my new tick tock
it's just
pearlythings.4.4 because it's my fourth
tick tock um our member of the week is
dragon stallion1001
message eddie if you want to come on the
show his link to his instagram is in the
description like the video and i will
talk to you guys next time
well done everybody
you